Hello Freak pitches of
the Internet of the world.
Who chose cross?
Yes.
Okay.
It's trying to get used to speak in
Mexican. Might have to go there soon.
David Seaman. I'm going to have
to evacuate to safer plasters.
I'd have to like where the drug wars,
it's hottest.
This episode of the Joe Rogan
experience podcast is brought to you by
squarespace.com if you go to
squarespace.com forward slash Joe,
you could try Squarespace
with no credit card needed.
Just try it out and start
building a website. Oh, website's.
So that's what's based basis about yes,
he had fucks you listening.
If you've never built a website before,
it can be a daunting task.
Looking at various pieces of software
that allow you to create your own websites
like [inaudible] or, I don't know,
I, it's, it's intimidating shit,
but the way Squarespace has it set up,
even a Mo Ron like me could
make a website very easily.
Brian is made about 60 of them
while the shows have been going on.
It's um, it's super sweet,
super sweet and easy to do.
Easy to set up an online store as well.
So you can, if you want to sell some shit,
you can be up and running like literally
in moments. It's, it's excellent.
You can choose your own custom images and
content and they uh, if you need help,
they have 24,
seven support,
super fast email support and
live online chat support. Um,
if you've never been there before and
thinking about hiring someone to check out
a website or to make you a bet website,
rather go check it out because you could
probably make one yourself that you
would really enjoy and give you
a little sense of satisfaction.
It's not hard to do anymore. It's
very intuitive. Um, uh, it's, it's uh,
like you can get a professional looking
website. They're not clunky though.
Never those Geo cities sites, you make
your own site and looked like dog shit.
No matter what you did.
This looks like a fucking awesome website
that someone would pay an ass load of
money to make.
So if you go use the code
name Joe and the number six,
all one word Joe,
number six,
and you will save 10% off your
first purchases on new accounts,
including monthly and annual plans.
So that's squarespace.com forward slash
Joe and again you can just try it out.
You don't have to,
you don't have to enter in your
credit card information to to use it.
You could just try it out for free and
then if you choose to use it, all right,
you know what I'm going to,
this is a fucking bad ass website.
Then you can go live with it. Use
a code. Joe Six save some cash.
Friend has a tanning company and she
just used it the other day and it was
literally like 10 minutes. She just had
all, all she wanted was her phone number,
her address where the people can contact
her and her services and she just like
typed it out and watched her do it
and it was like Bam chatted. I know.
It's amazing.
So ridiculous.
Well, we're happy that their sponsors
were also brought to you by legal zoom.
That's one of the newer sponsors and a
what I like about legal zoom besides what
David just told me,
that scared the shit out of me.
But uh,
what I really like about legal zoom
is that it's, it's really like,
it's expensive to go to a fucking lawyer
if you have a real problem you need to
deal with. If you have, um, you know,
anything business that you need to do,
you can start an LLC.
You could do it on legal zoom.
You can incorporate or
form an LLC for 99 bucks.
Researched that before you do it.
Yeah. Research. Oh, well, first of all,
legal zoom wants to state very
clearly that they're not a law firm.
They provide self help services at your
specific direction and they can also
connect you with an independent attorney
if you need additional guidance.
So check out legal zoom.com
and see what that's all about.
And use the code name,
Rogan in the referral box at checkout
and save yourself some cash if you have
any legal issues, whether
you want to, you know,
make a will for yourself or whether you,
uh, you know, when you want to form a, an,
an LLC or anything along those lines,
they check it out. They can do a lot,
a lot of stuff that you would normally
think that you would have to go to an
attorney for.
A,
they've helped over 2 million
Americans in the past 12 years.
So 2 million Americans have used legal
zoom. That's America. Fuck yeah. Use Them.
And they, you know, they send you like
a, uh, a big book and like if they,
I got a stamp with my corporation
on it and it's really cool.
That's bad ass using it.
What does it do they ask you what you
planning on doing with death squad as an
incorporation? How I think just, you know,
they make it go really crazy
straight to home that yeah.
That it goes straight
to homeland security.
They're looking right up your
ass son. It's really easy.
Yeah. So go check it out.
Legal zoom.com and use
the code name Brogan.
We're also brought to you by on
and.com. That's o, n n. I. T.
If you have never been and
you don't know what it is,
the way to describe it best,
it's probably a human
optimization site that's a,
that's how we like to think of it.
We tried to sell you shit that is uh,
the best available as far as strength
and conditioning equipment as far as
nutritional supplements,
like hemp protein powder,
like we sell Blendtec blenders and
kettle bells and all the different things
that, uh, I think are really beneficial
for health, for physical fitness.
And uh, we have, uh,
a lot of great endorsements are people
who try the stuff and really enjoy it.
What's going on in their
masturbating? I Dunno, it says MMA,
but that doesn't look like
masturbation associated.
So he's doing something really wrong.
Yeah,
it was like a metal that piece in there
and he doesn't seem like it's working
out.
We're doing the fusing choice out of
all the pictures that someone could have
put there. Maybe that's an
accident. Maybe the webmasters,
it'd be in a silly bitch cause that looks
like a screaming all he's coming. Yeah,
exactly. There's another man's holding
his hand. It looks like what is,
look that that's supposed to be an
arm bar. That's just ridiculous.
Why is it so subtly?
Like all the shadows around the
cock and balls and all those spots.
It's like to give you a sense of mystery.
What's he in a basement also? Yeah.
Why is he in the base? Mary homoerotic
with a rusty pipe behind them. Get it. Oh,
how dare they. How dare they. But other
than that on, it's got a lot of cool shit.
If you, uh, use a code name Brogan, you
will save 10% off any and all supplements.
Go, uh, buy some shit. Check
it out or not. Whatever.
You're a grown person.
Hopefully if you're not a grown person,
someone needs to get you the fuck
away from this recording right now.
Cause you're not ready for this.
But if you are a grown person,
do whatever you want to
do. Bitch, you got it.
But if you look at for medicine balls
are looking to buy some battle ropes.
Go get that shit.
It's holding greats greening.
And what does that, what does it like
a great, no, I think that's a barbell.
It's like she ain't really fast.
It's a glory hole and he's sticking his
hand through it and it's like sparks
rainbows coming in his hands.
Okay, that's it. Good night.
Go to [inaudible] dot com use the code
name Rogan and save 10% off any and all
supplements. Brian, it's good
to see you again buddy. Lost,
lost out in the woods. Hit
the hit the music, my friend.
Well good experience
Joe Rogan podcast.
I've been working like
seven days in a row. Really?
Totally bewildered. Excuse me.
Cause you said like, like, Hey, I'm in New
York. Hey, I'm in Vegas. I'm like, what?
Wait, what's going on here? Working
like a motherfucker. Dude, that's crazy.
I'm trying to get this show done by, uh,
which we, we started here in July 16th.
How many episodes? Everything we have.
Well, is there a conglomeration of him?
You know, so like we'll do
a one part of one episode,
one part of the day and then
another part of another episode,
another part of the day, it's, they're
not necessarily like we do one episode,
then we're done and then
we move onto another one.
We're filming like all six
of them at the same time.
So we're trying to smush everything
together. It's been very interesting.
But I just got back from the global
future 2045 conference in New York where I
got to meet a Aubrey de Grey and all
these life extension people in Doctor Amit
Goswami that had been on our podcast.
He was there as well and a
fascinating fucking shit.
So you got that where you look at
something like global future 2045 where
there's all these super geniuses trying
to figure out what the future of human
life is going to be like and whether
or not we'll be able to extend life,
download consciousness into
computers and all this crazy shit.
And then at the same time,
David Seaman,
he got a lot of fuckery going on,
man.
We're starting to learn how
much surveillance is being,
what's the word launched on the
American public on a daily basis.
I just want to use the end of this one.
I feel like every time I come here,
I have this hardcore doom and
gloom and Glen stuff to share.
And you guys are such a positive group
in general. So yeah, it's, it's a,
it's fucking scary what's going on. It's
hard not to take, well, I think it's,
it seems to have woken a lot of people up.
This is all kind of share that Alex
Jones would tell people about in like,
you know, 1990 [inaudible] Alex is
running around screaming all this shit.
And everybody was like, what? No one's
checking your email. But you know,
no one's done.
But it's slowly but surely.
It seems to be almost,
it seems to be almost inevitable that
you're going to get your email look that
scary.
Obama's over in Europe
right now and in Germany,
they were really upset about
these recent revelations.
And in Berlin he gives a speech saying,
uh, you know, now let me be clear.
No one's reading through
ordinary citizens emails.
We're not rifling through ordinary
people's emails. And you know,
he says this on international TV and
either doesn't read the news or like does
not understand what his own administration
is doing because that is what that
program does, which is why it caused
such an uproar. And similarly,
a 12 days ago, he said on national
TV in the u s when this first broke,
he said, uh, no one's
listening to your phone calls.
That's not what this program is about.
And that's the exact quote that people
can look up. And the, uh, you know,
that leaked court order from Verizon
business services is proof that actually,
uh, all of our phone calls are being
looked at and they say, just the Metadata,
which means who you're calling,
who's calling you those phone numbers.
Also the duration of the
call and your location.
Like not even just what
building we're in right now,
but what floor of the building we're on.
That's how accurate this shit is.
And they have this on everybody.
And just based on that metadata alone,
I could tell, you know, maybe not me,
but an actual trained analyst
could immediately tell if
you're having an affair,
if you sought help for
depression or anxiety by
calling a psychiatrist's office,
uh,
if you're having financial problems,
you're contacting tax
consultants and all this shit.
So within a few minutes
from your metadata,
they know far more about your life then
the government possibly should know,
especially if you have nothing to hide,
then you're not doing anything wrong.
It's just shocking that it was all going
on and no one was speaking out about it
until this one dude.
And he comes out with it
and now he's on the run.
He's hiding. I was looking on the, the
front of a USA Today and it was in my, uh,
hotel and it said like some,
you know,
65% of Americans think Edward
Snowden should be put on trial.
Actually,
the American people I think had been
pretty good about knowing that they're
being bullshitted right now.
Like it's something like two thirds want
to see a congressional investigation
not into stolen, but into these programs.
And if they're targeting Americans.
And, uh, one, uh,
one thing I want to put out here before
I forgot about it is we keep the debate
is like, well, should
we do this to Americans?
And it's a given at this point
that we are absolutely 100%,
no doubt about it doing
this to people in Europe.
People in Asia are supposed to
trading, responding, spying on them.
And these are still human beings
too. I mean, they're not US citizens,
but should ordinary people who have
no links to radicalism or terrorism,
should they have their personal stuff
rifled through by somebody who is, uh,
an analyst at the NSA,
basically a government employee.
These aren't people who have taken years
of training and they've lost their ego
and some kind of like a razzle ghoul
ceremony, like in a dark night, you know,
they don't train on the ice and, uh,
lose themselves and some greater cause.
They're just people who saw a fucking
newspaper advertisement and applied for
this job at Fort Meade and now they
have access to an unbelievable amount of
information about ordinary people
all over the world. That's crazy.
So it's not just metadata.
The are absolute emails.
There's two theories and I'll share both
of them and you can decide which one's
true.
So we know with 100% certainty that
they are looking at metadata of innocent
people. It appears to be all phone
records within the United States.
And if they're doing that here,
you can assume that they're pretty much
doing it everywhere because that's what
the NSA does. They're not even supposed
to be doing this stuff on us soil, but uh,
are not supposed to be doing it unless
they have a specific foreign target
within the United States.
All of this stuff,
the NSA does made sense
back during the Cold War.
So if you'd have like a Soviet agent
come to the u s and you suspect them of
doing spy shit,
you want to wait in,
you wouldn't have a way to tap into
their phone calls while they're in the
United States. So it made sense to
do this kind of stuff back then.
It never made sense to turn
it in on American citizens.
And that's where seeing whistleblowers
now come out and say, this is wrong,
this is not the way this program
was set up, et cetera. And uh,
yeah,
so the two,
the two theories are definitely made a
data and then the actual contents of your
phone calls and emails
according to some people, uh,
is being logged and NSA servers,
no matter who you are,
you could be the most innocent
person out there who's never, uh,
never even smoked a joint or looked
at any kind of Alex Jones website.
And you're still having your emails and
phone calls logged on a server somewhere
and they're not accessed unless they
have reason to suspect you of a crime and
they get some kind of court approval
and then they access all your phone
conversations.
That's theory one and theory too,
is that they're actually
not recording everything.
They're just recording the
recording the metadata.
And if you're on their target list,
then they're recording all of your
phone calls and emails. But if not,
they're only looking at the metadata.
And what's so scary about theory too,
which is, you know, the more
conservative theory, it's not as uh,
not as frightening as the other theory.
What's fucked up about it is
that according to William Binney,
the other NSA whistleblower,
there are several of them.
The way that you get targeted is once
you're introduced to somebody else's
community, you're now added to the target
list. So I'll just give you an example.
In the past stuff had conversations with
journalists who am almost certain or
being uh, or on the NSA target list just
cause they cover really sensitive stuff.
So since I've had conversations
with them by email and by phone,
I'm now a part of their community
and I'm added to the target list,
which means that all my phone calls
being logged in a server somewhere,
the actual content. So if they need to,
they can listen to them in the future.
And by you talking to me right now,
that makes you a part of my community.
And now you're on the target list and
if you talk to somebody next week,
they're on the target list and
it just keeps going. And going.
And so there are millions of people
on this list. The whole world. Yeah.
I mean that becomes the whole world.
Well you look at the justifications,
they're using a completely absurd,
they say if your communications
are only us communications,
we are definitely not intercepting them.
But you know,
if you have a lot of followers on Twitter,
it's a hundred percent certain that you've
interacted with Twitter followers who
are not living in the United States.
If you've ever received an
email that's like a spam email,
it's almost certain that that did not
originate on a US server at originated
somewhere in Europe or Russia. Uh,
and you know, when you visit websites,
most of the shit you look at is not
based in the u s so whenever you do those
shit, you look at Boston
Baba, come on sign,
I'm on American websites all day.
Pornhub is American
from what I understand.
So can you like just forward your phone
number to like a home phone number and
then like direct your text messages
through a website that you know,
isn't recording or information.
Like,
is there some kind of hack that you can
hack yourself? Well, what tank phone,
what's so bad about this from
an economic perspective is, uh,
there are already companies that are
positioning themselves is where us free.
You know,
your data won't be stored in the U S it's
like we're infected now with this out
of control,
corrupt government and people.
And what sucks about that is we're
the ones who make this shit happen.
Like cloud storage, innovative stuff
like Facebook and Google, you know,
content companies like, uh, like
youtube and stitcher and all this stuff.
This is what we're good at as a country
and we export all around the world and
now we're like tainted goods
because you can't trust us anymore.
I've government is too crazy just for
the same reason that a lot of companies
don't want to do business in China
because it would mean, you know,
like buying off a lot of people
and dealing with a lot of bullshit.
Now the US is becoming a place where,
you know, great people, great innovation,
but the government is too
volatile and you can't trust it.
And that that's terrible because that
means that we're not going to be the ones
who pull ahead over the next 50 years.
It's so fucked up because if you
talk to people, uh, that, you know,
normal folks in America that will
exhibit some sort of patriotism,
they have an idea of what America
is like everyone's idea of America.
This is America's, you know, hey,
this is a truly free crunch country
where a person is not tied down by their
lineage. They can make something out of
themselves. A lot of success stories,
a nation of free thinking individuals.
We have all of these like positive things
that we attached to it. But God damn,
if we're not governed by a bunch
of paranoid fucking Weirdos
yeah.
And they wrap themselves in the flag.
I think most Americans are good people,
obviously, or I wouldn't be here.
And uh, it's not the people and
it's not the companies here.
It's the government has gone
beyond the bounds that were set up.
Isn't that what happens when,
like if you have a,
a paradigm that you've been operating
under and then all of a sudden that
paradigm just dissolving under you,
like,
like rising tide and you know
what's happening. So what do you do?
You tried to put a bunch of crazy
laws in place to try to stop it.
He tried to be able to check out and
you fucking put the fear of God and
everybody check out all their emails.
Look at all the Dick Pics,
look at all their phone calls.
They're making a three o'clock in
the morning when they're drunk.
Look at everything. Look at
everything. I got you bitch.
You better keep your fucking mouth shut.
We're going to keep running it this way.
Well, it's uh, what's crazy is the
director of the NSA, Keith Alexander,
a General Keith Alexander,
uh,
he was giving testimony before Congress
and I think this was either earlier
today or yesterday.
And at the end of his testimony,
he didn't realize that the
mic was still hot next to him.
And he leans over to one
of his aides and says,
I need to buy your boss a freaking beer,
talking about the FBI guys who were
testifying in support of this program.
And so, you know, at the end of the
day what he said, that's nothing wrong.
Of course, the FBI and the NSA collaborate
there. You know, that's what they do.
Their intelligence agencies and law
enforcement agents or the case, the FBI,
you know what I'm saying, or did
the same shit. And uh, so nothing,
he said there was wrong.
These,
that's actually shows that he's a human
being and it goes out to drink beer
every now and then. It isn't
this, you know, a computer. Uh,
so nothing you said was wrong,
but just that single line, uh,
that he didn't want the world
to hear in the world heard, uh,
has been analyzed to death online. It
hit the front page of Reddit. People are,
you know, in conspiracy land now. And
if you think like, you know, this guy,
he didn't want that line of
conversation to hit the wrong people.
What about every single text
message you've ever sent?
Every single website you've ever sent?
It's kind of, it's richly ironic, right?
It's showing that this is
not a good system. Even if
you have nothing to hide, uh,
maybe you don't want your future employer
to see every porn website you've been
to,
every medical condition you've looked up
and every deleted text message from the,
uh, you know, the woman you're seeing,
it's just not their fucking place
to see that in the first place.
And then why extend that power to a
government agent who is just somebody who
applied for a job and happens
to have a clean record?
That's all an NSA analyst is. Again,
they're not people who have, you know,
detached themselves from the ego and
they're driven only by love of country.
I would hope that's what
most of them are there for.
But we don't know that people are people.
And that's why we have a constitution.
That's why we have the bill of rights
is to prevent this from happening in the
first place.
This is very well put and um,
I think unfortunately the reality of our
times is that things are moving in the
direction of a complete elimination
of all boundaries between people and
information. I just don't know
if there's any way to stop it.
And when you find out
that the people with the,
you can't say like the
ability to like what,
what the government is doing,
they have to do and secretly in secrecy
because no one is going to allow it.
No one is going to say like,
yeah,
I fully support you listening to every
fucking email to stop the occasion.
Are you chewing ice? You motherfucker
stop the occasional tea. I mean,
think about how many terrorism,
how many terrorist,
how many people die of terrorism as
opposed to how many people died just from
drinking alcohol or smoking cigarettes.
Right?
The government doesn't try to ever
get you to stop doing those things,
but way more people die from them than
are ever going to probably got die from
terrorism.
I mean 400,000 people every year die
from cigarettes and you never hear the
government talking about how
cigarettes are the enemy.
What they're doing is they're,
they're trying to keep people scared
and by trying to keep people scared,
they can continue to govern things
the way they're doing it. And the way.
So the way to be able to check out all
your email and keep everybody back on
their heels is to say,
we have to protect you from terrorism.
We're trying to stop terrorism
and the way to stop terrorism,
we just got to check everything.
You gotta you gotta look
at everybody's Dick Pic.
Yeah.
You got to look at it.
And then if we happen to find out along
the way that you're gay, you're gay,
and you're going to be,
oh,
you're going to be running for some office
in the future or that you have cancer
or that you spoke marijuana and you
happen to live in a conservative state and
you're a congressman who plans
on investigating the NSA,
they can just give you a little heads up,
you know,
maybe think twice before you say anything
on that oversight committee. And uh,
I'm not saying this stuff is happening,
but like my,
I guess my whole issue is why wouldn't
it happen if they'd been this dishonest
about the extent to which they're spying
on people and now they're like, oh,
we're transparent.
Yeah.
After a whistle blower goes to Hong
Kong at the risk of his life and reveals
these documents,
then you're transparent and then,
then there's a credibility problem.
It's the difference between you
calling the IRS. I mean like, look,
I'm a little bit behind on
my taxes difference between
that and them being like,
what does this account in the Caymans,
you know, what is this all about?
It's still, it's a huge
difference. Same with anything.
It's like going to your girlfriend and
saying you fucked up about something
versus her finding out.
And then you have to explain yourself
and that's what the government is doing
now.
And the two arguments they're making or
to anyone who's reasonably intelligent
or not acceptable, they say, this
is nothing new. This is all routine.
This is no big deal.
Well then why are you treating the sky
as if he's blown the cover off something
huge.
If this is no big deal.
Why did Senator Lindsey Graham said that
he will go to the ends of the earth to
track this guy down?
You know,
why are they treating him as if he's
such a threat to national security?
If we all knew that all of our
shit was being looked at anyway?
Well, we definitely did all know that.
Right? There's no doubt about that.
But there was some concern about the,
the facility that we're building in Utah.
I had heard about that online. Uh, you,
you had spoken about it. Um, uh,
Michael Rupert spoken about it,
that they're building a
facility that stores everything.
It's going to be a massive, gigantic
data center. And the idea is, look,
if you don't do anything wrong,
they never going to look into it.
But the reality is who are they
and how did they get that position?
They're just human beings.
The laws change over time. Like just to
give you a, a nightmare scenario 2016,
let's say we get a president,
uh, what's his fucking name?
President Santorum or President
Rick Perry is somebody like that.
And because they feel like this is
a good way to gain support from the
conservative base,
they go on a morality platform,
which has happened before in the
United States. Look, prohibition,
they go on a morality
platform. They say, look,
the the U s is falling behind
shine on the countries.
The reason why is that were soft,
you know,
or a bunch of druggies and a bunch
of alcoholics. So from here on out,
we're not just going to continue
to keep marijuana criminalized.
We're going to super criminalize it and
just eradicated from the United States.
And so what they do in that case,
it's,
even though you know it wasn't illegal
four years ago to send emails to your
friends talking about the
medical marijuana clinic
that you go to in California,
even though that's totally fine in 2013
and 2016 it's no longer legal to talk
about those things and to promote that
ideology and all you have to do is do a
keyword search in their database and
find everybody who is sympathetic to
marijuana reform, it make their lives
a little bit more difficult. You know,
maybe hit them with audits are
trumped up charges or anything.
When that happens, you're not living
in a representative democracy. You're,
you're looking at,
you're living in a place for unelected
people or people who you know,
have been elected in and corrupted or
making decisions for you and there's
nothing you can do about it and you don't
even know the decisions are being made
until it impacts you personally.
Yeah, and this is really a pattern that
has repeated itself over and over again
throughout human history.
And it was,
it's really exactly what the founding
fathers of this country we're trying to
prevent.
When they crafted the constitution,
they were trying to protect against this
continual cycle of people getting to
power and then abusing that power. It
just, it happens. It's always happened.
It's the way humans do it and slowly but
surely they've chipped away at it with
things like Nda or the Patriot Act and
they do it and they do it while nothing's
happening.
They're not like they're doing it and why
bombs are blowing up over the overhead
and we need to declare martial law and
figure out what's going on. A lock,
everything down.
It's not like that at all.
They're just recognizing the tide coming
in and they're scrambling and they're
trying to find all sorts of new ways to
get at data, but in the meantime though,
their data is being captured.
It's funny you said the tide's coming
in because one of the best theories I've
seen so far and why they're
doing all this stuff.
I was published in the Guardian newspaper
the other day and the theory that this
one guy proposed is that the government
strongly believes that economic and
possibly energy, uh, unrest. So the
price of fuel as well as you know,
people's wages and their savings,
all of that stuff is going to be
an upheaval in the near future.
And the reason why is climate change.
If you think about New York City,
if just the tide levels rise by a couple
of feet, you're talking about, you know,
the New York Stock Exchange flooding
out and that market being closed for a
couple of weeks at the minimum and
you know, total financial chaos,
not to mention all the people who lose
their lives and the flooding. So you,
if you realize how serious climate changes
and that half the country, you know,
that sort of Fox News view is just a
market and pretend like it's bullshit.
This is happening.
And apparently the government is concerned
about the unrest that will come from
just one major catastrophe, that people
will start to protest the government the,
so you didn't do your job,
you should have known about
this beforehand and there
will be just upheaval.
So what pisses me off about this is if
that's the reason why the government is
storing all of our emails is so they
can pick out all the influencers within
protest groups in the future,
if that's what this is all about,
it's fucking absolutely disgusting
that they're using their considerable
resources and technology to,
uh,
make sure that protests don't take off
in the u s instead of using that talent
and technology to prevent these things
from happening in the first place.
You know,
let's tackle climate change.
Let's figure out how we don't have
a drought in the future. Right?
But the, but what you're
saying is very general. The,
you're dealing with a bunch
of compartmentalize people.
And so if you're attacking
their specific thing,
the thing with whether it's the
IRS or whether it's the NSA,
if you're going after their specific
department, they're not going to thank,
you know what? We need to just put a
man on the moon. You know, they're,
they're not thinking like that.
They're thinking we have to
protect our organization. Right.
It's toxic because it's
corporation thinking. It's
corporate thinking with guns.
You said, man, on the moon,
our grandparents put humans on the moon
and now we're just trying to fight.
The government's not read our emails.
It's like we're moving backwards in time.
Well, it's, um, there's,
there's a lack of privacy that is just
overwhelmingly apparent when you look at
the future. If you
extrapolate the future, the,
the lack of privacy is the thing that
people dread the most over the last few
years. Whether it's someone hacking
into your email or someone you know,
spying on your phone calls or there
the fact that it now is completely a
reality.
That was like something that people were
really worried about for a long time.
As it,
as it gets more and more invasive,
as technology permeates your life
more and more, it's going to,
it's going to reach some point
where we have neural chips. Well,
we have a headpiece that we,
where we have something
that's not so bad. If it's
open to everyone, it will
be, you know, the bidding.
Right now it's only the government
looking at it, so it's a one way mirror.
I really believe,
I know people give me shit about this
and they think it's a very utopian way of
looking at the world,
but I,
I truly believe that this,
this new age that we're entering into
this age of complete openness is going to
force people to be accountable.
It's going to change behavior
and even the people that govern,
they're going to govern differently.
It's kind of, they're going to have to,
they're going to want to,
you're not going to want to feel the
repercussions from all these people that
you're doing something wrong. You're
going to feel bad, you're going to change.
It's not a good life to be
suppressing and bullying and dominating
people and and using dirty tactics like
reading their emails to control your
political agenda and to contaminate your
opponents. It's evil and it's not good
for you either. The person who does it,
it's shit for you. You're going to
get cancer. You're going freak out.
You're going to the negative energy that
you're putting out there in the world.
That's not a free ride.
You can't be some global fucking asshole,
you know,
that's poisoning third
world countries for profit.
You can't be that guy and sleep like a
baby and wake up with a smile. You're,
you're a flawed human being.
It's unconsciousness.
I've thought a lot about this,
about why these consultant companies are
working with the government to spy on
American citizens and
they're even building similar
systems for Middle Eastern
countries where you know,
at least here we can tell ourselves that
Obama will never use this against us
and that there are these
posted safeguards in place,
which really why would we tell ourselves
that though that's what people do.
We don't like to think that
it could happen here, but,
but let me just play this out.
The same companies that built that shit
over here and maintain it are building
similar systems in the Middle East.
And those countries are corrupt monarchies
that have no qualms about using it to
do exactly what I said,
to figure out who the protesters are,
to pull them out of their
homes and torture them until
they stopped protesting.
And it's, it's appalling to me that
American companies are involved in this.
And I kept thinking, how is this
possible? You know, cause I know some,
I know some people who work in the
defense field and stuff of that nature,
those kinds of companies, and
they're like, they're not bad people.
And I think what it is
is this unconsciousness.
You have people who were around that Guy
Edward Snowden's age around my age who
are making more money than they
should be making, you know,
$200,000 a year and just these assholes
wearing khakis flying all over the
world. And they're in a position of
privilege, you know, airport lounges, uh,
you know,
attractive women.
They make more than most people that
age make and they have access to
extraordinary power and they're doing
this because they've been told that that's
what you're supposed to do after college,
you should be successful.
You want to make a lot of money,
have a nice girlfriend,
do these things and so you're
just in this little pool,
this isolated pool of other people who
are doing the same thing as you and so
you're like,
well my friend Tom,
he's making $215,000 a year so I have
to do a good job on this NSA project to
make sure I'm like two 40 next year
and can take my girlfriend is some nice
place in the Hamptons for a week and
these people are not the ones ruling the
world.
They're just the pawns for the 65 year
old 70 year old dudes who actually run
these defense companies and
why are they doing this stuff?
They have more money than God.
They don't need to continue doing
the same things over and over again.
I think they're doing it because it
becomes competitive at that point.
They want to get invited to next year's
Bilderberg and jerk each other off or
whatever it is they do at these things.
They want to be in the club.
And if you stop a,
if you're no longer a part of the process,
you kind of fall out of the club.
And that's what it's about.
It's unconsciousness.
People feel like there's no other way.
Like that's the way you should live your
life is to gain more and more influence
until you die.
And maybe that's not the right approach.
Well,
human beings are incredibly malleable,
mean we're able to adapt to
strange situations and we're,
we're able to rise and fall to incredible
heights and depths. I mean, we're,
we're fucking weird man. We don't,
we're not standard. You know,
there's not like a normal human,
like the way humans,
very luck in behavior and
personality and capabilities.
It's not like anything
in the animal kingdom.
A tiger is a fucking tiger
is a fucking tiger. You know,
you could feed one and if you're lucky,
associates you with being a good
thing because you feed them.
But if one day he decides to go
Siegfried and Roy on you, that's,
that's his choice. Okay. There's
nothing you can do about that.
Humans are so different.
There's,
there's so much variability and it's,
it's weird. There's so many variables.
It's the the,
to make a good human is
incredibly difficult and
until we concentrate on making
good people, until we concentrate on
the impoverished people in this country,
this world even, I mean, until we
look at the weakest link of humanity,
if we really do look at humanity,
we want to pretend we're humane.
We really do look at it collectively.
The thing you have to do is you've
got to stop all these bad spots.
If you have a foundation
and the foundation is all
fucked up with worms and and
termites and shit,
you've got to cut that out and rebuild it.
If you don't have a good foundation,
you're fucked. If you look at any society,
look at the weakest link.
The weakest link is its biggest problem
and the weakest link of his country's
completely ignored. Poor people
like, fuck you. Get your own.
Figure it out. Fuck yourself. There's
so little money being put into it.
You have to pay for school.
You know when,
when it comes to colleges and
always going to pay for it. I mean,
maybe I can get a grant if you're
lucky. Try getting the grant. Okay,
you got to Gregg.
Congratulations.
Not trying to get an a job
once you get out of there. Oh,
back to the back to the situation,
right.
Oh dollars an hour or unemployed.
Massive struggle to try to get out of
that situation and no resources put to try
to solve it.
Like social engineering as a culture.
Like let's look at our
brothers and sisters and say,
well how can we help them?
How can we make sure that these babies
aren't growing and he's incredibly toxic
environments?
They're going to be damaged human beings
that go out to inflict more bullshit on
society. All of that can be avoided
if you cut it off at the path.
All that can be avoided. It sounds so
cliche, but with love and understanding,
and if you treated it that way and realize
that we're not going to fucking be in
this thing forever and we now for the
first time ever all have access to the
right amount of information where
we should be able to sort this out.
We should all be able to understand like
what the fuck is really going on with
human behavior, what's really
going on with the, the,
the way corporations can
act as an individual.
But yet no one inside the corporation
feels anything that the individuals doing
that's horrible
when everyone wants to fuel and they
feel that way to become a whistle blower.
And then the media says that there are
a trader and you know, a, a narcissist.
The Sky has turned down.
By the way,
the Guy Snowden is turned down every
single major TV interview that has been
thrown his way, which is pretty much
all of them. So if he's a narcissist,
why is he turning down all of the press?
He's clearly and why would he destroy
his life? That makes no sense.
Clearly that's bullshit.
But that's what happens is when you're
in a corporation or an organization,
you see that the stuff around you is
not functioning the way it should.
That person's a whistle blower
if they choose to step up.
And instead of us being as a society,
like Holy Shit,
that person did a heroic
thing there for sure.
Getting a big ass book deal and we're
gonna get laid for the rest of their lives
because of what they've
done for this country.
Instead of that being the paradigm
where we reward those people,
it's like trader,
you know
later and you want to step back
because you don't want to get caught,
right. You don't want to be
connected to that and uh,
they can never get a job again. Like
Thomas Drake, the other NSA whistleblower,
they're actually several
of them. Thomas Drake, his,
his life over the past few years sounds
like a movie and it probably will be a
movie someday soon.
He was a senior executive at the NSA or
a senior official there and saw what was
going on and saw there
was deeply unamerican and
unconstitutional and became a
whistleblower.
And they went after him with everything
they had charged them under the
espionage act.
And uh,
now he ended up not going to prison.
He was very fortunate in that respect,
not to go to prison, but now he works
at an apple store as an hourly retail,
a rep, just that fucking apple store
telling people about the new iPhone.
And this was a guy who was privy to
the government's most sophisticated
technological secrets. And now he's
telling people how to refresh their mail,
maybe likes it. And that's a good
gig. That's a relaxing no technology.
And I'm saying it's a great Gig,
but if you're one of the
smartest people in the country,
to the point where the NSA recruits you,
these are not stupid.
So you're saying that he
can't get a job anywhere else.
Same reason why he's there,
but he's blackballed
is other intelligent. Other intelligence
agencies don't want that person around.
When really if you're not doing anything
wrong and you're a big company or a big
government agency, you should want to
recruit people like that to show them off.
You know, look, we hired this
guy, so we're above board.
We're not doing anything illegal,
but they don't do that.
Those people are kind of fucked for life.
Maybe get the fuck this guy.
Maybe it wasn't that smart to begin with.
It was just whoever hired him was
his dumb. Maybe he's a trader,
he could be a trader. I look, you know,
and I don't mean to demean
his accomplishments or what
he did or his courage in
any way in real life.
We're joking around the the re.
The reality though is you're
absolutely right. Brave man. Yeah,
you're absolutely right. And you're
absolutely right that it's, it's, it's,
it's real travesty and it's,
it's sad that we all look at
America as like one thing,
but if you see at the root of it, like
the people that are running it, what they,
the disdain that they have for the
privacy of the American people,
it's the rights.
Horrendous rights are the rights
and they want to chip away at them.
And even a guy like Obama, which
is, I was, man, when Obama won,
I was so fucking happy when he
first became president. I was like,
oh my God. Like we really have
like broken through the cloud.
I was,
I was in union square at the time with
my girlfriend in New York and there was
like mist in the air. I'm not making this
up. There was actually mist in the air.
There's just a sea of people like
cheering him on with this big TV screen.
And I voted for him in 2008. And I was
definitely a part of that. You know,
the Koolaide drinking club of hope
and change. And yes, we can, you know,
he said yes, we can. It doesn't mean
that he actually would. And uh, you know,
like I bought it,
I bought into it completely.
And that's part of the reason why I've
becomes such a critic is covering these
stories over the past year and a half.
You see that his great speeches have
almost no correlation to what he is
actually doing.
After the TV turns off.
And he goes back to running his
administration and that's what,
that's what really like,
uh, it makes my blood boil.
Like you just were talking about
Obama before my phone dies.
I really want to read,
this is from MSN news.
It's not from like some right wing site,
like a Glenn Beck or something like that.
So he's planning a trip to Africa and
they're saying it might be the most
expensive presidential trip ever. This
is a quote from MSN news. The trip,
which begins June 26th could
cost 60 million to $100
million and could be one of
the most expensive presidential
trips in United States history.
One unnamed source told The Washington
Post the higher estimate cost of this
month's trip is partially due to
elaborate security provisions. Uh,
let me just read the actual stats.
Resources will reportedly include
hundreds of us secret service agents and a
Navy aircraft carrier with a fully
staffed medical trauma center.
Military cargo planes
will transport 56 support,
vital support vehicles including 14
limousines and three trucks loaded with
sheets of bulletproof glass to cover
the windows of the hotels were the first
family will stay. And my question is,
is that a reasonable use of money?
14 limousines.
Why can't we just have two or three
and this guy's a president of a
constitutional republic or is he
the emperor of some high tech,
a dystopian society that spies on
the whole world and deploys drones to
countries that we don't like to kill
people on the basis of this secret
information we're obtaining through
their email and you start to wonder like
we've strayed pretty far from the the
farmers and the 13 colonies who were like,
we need to, you know, a form of
government that is going to resist future,
you know,
power grabs.
We're in a totally different world
from what they envisioned. Yeah.
We're like super techno gangster.
That's really what it is.
Vertech techno gangster society that's
controlling resources everywhere.
We're like Rome times a million.
Yeah. I think if you were to beam Julius
Caesar to the present day, who'd be like,
God Damn Obama. Yeah, he, he
would, he would be impressed.
It would take about an afternoon or
two to bring them up to speed on the
internet, podcasts, satellites. Once you
do that though, they're exactly the same.
I guess I'm being kind of harsh enough.
I don't,
but I think ideologically they're
exactly the same. Kind of, yeah.
Well they're not the.live in
the same time. If they were
living in the same time,
they'd have probably similar behavior.
Yeah.
That's the thing that people have to
realize is that there's so many steps
removed from the person in charge of the
country or the person in charge of the
army, even in the brutalization that
happens on the ground, you know,
and Obama is very, very far removed from
the brutalization that happens. In fact,
the weird new kind of brutalization that
happens where everyone's removed except
the people that get hit.
That's what's so strange about drones.
The idea that someone could be no where
near where this is happening and do
something that causes someone to stop
living and that it happens on a regular
basis. Yeah. It's the ultimate detachment
from reality. I mean, and it's,
it's an excellent technological solution
as far as like saving troops and all
that stuff.
If you looked at it that way,
if you want it to be pragmatic
on the side of Americans,
but it's not that effective,
it kills a lot of people that it's not
supposed to kill. It kills a lot of kids.
It's killed many kids and it's, it's
creepy. Something creepy about it.
Yeah.
It's uh,
it's too much disconnection between
people you're killing and it's too easy.
It's too easy to do it to Americans
where you don't even have to go to trial.
Speaking of too easy, uh, this'll
freak freak everybody out a little bit,
but oh Geez. I'm so the, the list,
we've already broken the precedent of
targeting and killing American citizens
without a trial using drones for us
citizens have been killed that way,
that we know of. And granted the one guy
was an asshole and probably deserved it.
But the other three,
we don't really know.
The one guy was the guy who turned out
tell about some Muslim propagandist.
If you're actually proper guy
propagandizing people and you know,
inciting them to violence,
then you're an asshole and you
really kind of get what you deserve.
But we've now created that slippery
slope and I give it a slippery slope.
We've gone down the slope now we've
actually killed American citizens with
drones. So in the future court
cases, we'll look back to that.
That's the precedent that we'd
done it. You know, President Obama,
the thoughtful liberal constitutional
law scholar thinks that it's okay.
So it's certainly okay for a president,
Rick Perry to do that.
And he keeps saying that cause that's
the scariest outcomes saying that.
I think he just recently, uh, I
think either in Texas or in Florida,
they're trying to make it a felony to
even flown to Florida two pipes if you get
caught twice. So that's why I keep saying
that cause that's a real possibilities.
You get somebody like that in the Oval
Office and they have all these toys and
they use it in the worst way as possible.
And all you'll hear about it is,
you know,
Erin Burnett on CNN saying some,
some radical terrorists were killed
last night and they happen to be in the
United States. And most Americans will
go, well, good. I want to be safe.
I don't want those people here anyways.
And you don't look into the fact that,
well, what did they actually
done? They did nothing.
They were just on the wrong list and they
planned on attending some protest and
now they're vaporized. I'm not saying
that's going to happen tomorrow,
but I'm saying we've 100% laid the
legal groundwork for that to happen.
That's essentially Kent
State, 2013 style. Right.
So essentially what the or Ruby Ridge
or any of that stuff? Well, yeah, well,
Ken state especially, I don't know
what really happened on Ruby Ridge.
I don't know, uh, how Kooky that dude was
when they were shooting at people. Yeah.
Do you know? No, I, I don't know. I
wasn't there obviously. So Kent State,
it was just students.
Just Moa.
Yes. I mean the, the whole
us versus them. Shit,
I think is way harder to pull off today
though because the cops realize that
they're not the Bilderberg group. They're
not, they're not chilling with Obama,
you know,
eating caviar on a nuclear submarine,
right? Yeah. They're not
spending $100 million.
Their vacation and their kids are
not going to these elite schools.
Well,
it's not only that they,
they have to know at this point in
time that they are the, exactly,
the cops are exactly the same as
the people that are arresting. Okay.
They're just regular citizens.
No. A cop is just like you.
He just has a different job in a different
loyalty and then he becomes a part of
a team and then he has
loyalty to that team.
They cover up for each other and
then you might never dirty boss.
He might have a boss.
It's good, but it's like,
that's exactly what it becomes
is it becomes a person,
just a person who becomes a part
of a community and then assimilate.
And when the community's rotten,
it's very difficult to, to be clean.
It's very difficult.
Look at,
I mean we all assumed that Obama was
this like super awesome guy and we all
assumed that he was going to go
in there and switch things up.
Let's assume that he actually was,
look,
let's assume that he actually was who
he seemed to be his entire life up until
he became president.
That just goes to show you how rotten
the community that he got. Yeah.
Inserted into, he got inserted into
some shit. It's just completely fucked
and it's not too late for
him to do the right thing.
He's a second term president. Well, if he
were to go through with just, you know,
I don't think you're on a 10% of the
stuff he promised in the campaign trail.
You start to reign in these things that
he was supposed to have done. Yeah.
Then it's not too late to change things,
but I,
I'm not saying that's gonna happen.
I think he is already,
he has shown us his cards and whatever
remaining shred of respect I had for the
guy.
I lost it after watching that press
conference on June 7th June 7th or eighth
where he lied to the American people.
He said,
we're not listening to your phone calls.
That's not what this program is about. A,
that's, that's lawyer speak. Cause the
metadata tells you so much about people.
And B,
it appears that you actually are listening
to phone calls and a lot of cases.
So either you don't know what
your own administration is doing,
which is possible,
in which case you need to fucking fire
those people and have an independent
investigation and to why they're
doing something against your wishes.
Or you do know about this and it's a
total one 80 from everything you said on
the campaign trail. Like people
always say to me, they're like, well,
Bush started these programs.
I don't see why you're giving Obama such
a hard time. And I go, that's right.
But Obama didn't say, I'm
going to be, you know,
aggressively continuing
the same path as Bush.
Young people got out to vote
because he said enough. You know,
American needs a clean slate.
We're not doing this post
nine 11 craziness anymore.
We're going to have the rule of law,
I'm a constitutional law scholar,
all that stuff.
And then we find out that secretly the
program has actually been expanding and
bringing all these new companies
on board to harvest our data.
And I think that's when I lost that,
that final shred of respect cause I'd
already been covering like Nda and the
growth, the Tsa and all these things that
I disagree with. And then you're like,
wait a second, why are you doing this? You
know, now there's no shadow of a doubt.
Like you either don't know what
you're on government is doing,
in which case you're bad at your job or
you do know and you're being dishonest
with Americans.
How much power do you think he has?
He's the most powerful person in
the world. Do you think that's real?
I think that's real. Or else why? Why
would it matter much who we choose?
I think he's the so, but does it, I mean
it does, doesn't it get boiled down?
First of all, the two parties,
which is bullshit. Second of all to,
to people that are absolutely
supported by gigantic corporations.
It's not like there's any rogue
independence that sneak through. He went,
he went to war with Libya
basically unilaterally, right?
I mean you're,
you're an influential guy.
You can't go on Twitter and decided to
start a war with Libya. This guy, he,
you keep saying he because we don't,
but this is where my dispute it.
Am I not be Obama who we don't, I don't
know. I don't necessarily not leave that.
They would allow a new person to come
in every four years and just run shit.
And that's possible also because if
the NSA is doing with what we now know
they're doing, what if they're like, look,
we know you have all these plans
to do a, B, and c for the country,
but we have these really kind of
embarrassing phone calls between you and
whoever.
His doesn't even have to do that.
Does anyone have anything but enough to
compromise him and or just maybe just
seduce them with that level of power?
Have you ever tried to do anything where
you have to involve a bunch of people
that also get to make decisions?
Yeah,
it becomes a Dick Swing and contrast
that to but trying to get to hang around
with a rubber band more often. I
feel you definitely do. I benefit.
You definitely wear a condom.
The um, like it's, it's,
it's real easy to get caught up
in the, you know, the, the whole,
the hustle of how you're living
and to, to not have, uh, the, the,
the ability to step back and take a
deep breath and look at the whole thing
collectively and what Obama and all these
other guys are doing is just playing
into the direction that it's been
going and been going forever,
but only going right now at least on
the level that they can achieve the,
it has to be someone at the highest levels
of government that can store all the
data of all the phone calls all
over the world. But that's just now.
I feel like what they can do now by
listening to every phone call and reading
every text you're going to be able
to do in a hundred years from now,
five years from now, whatever
it is, 10 years from now.
I don't think there's any room
in this world for secrets,
but what about it gets a left
over thing that we cherish?
The financial aspect of being able to
spy on people around the world. Well,
in here it gets even deeper.
What about the financial aspect of
resources being broken down to a digital
thing? Look at what money used
to be. Money was a gold standard.
It was set on goal.
There was $100 worth of gold or something
that represented a hundred dollars
with a goal.
It doesn't mean shit anymore.
It means ones and Zeros that are
written down on paper somewhere or on a
computer. That's it. That's what it
means is based entirely on confidence.
You know, and that's obviously a gross
simplification of the financial system,
but that's just because
that's all I can do.
I don't really understand
how it actually works.
It is a total confidence game from what
I understand. But the bottom line is it,
it doesn't represent
anything anymore. It's becoming, computers
can become in ones and Zeros. Well,
when we get to that point,
which is fucking calming, okay,
we want to pretend that we,
everyone hates the idea of socialism.
Everyone hates the idea of
communism, me included. You know why?
Because people are fucking shady
and they don't do their part.
And it would be great if we all made the
exact same amount of money if we're all
worked hard. But that's not where
people's motivation come from.
People's motivations come from you work,
you achieve something,
and then you feel how good that feels.
Then you want to continue doing that.
But if you give someone
something really easily,
they become spoiled and we can lazy.
That's the problem with,
that's a problem with rich kids.
That's the problem with celebrities.
Well, that's how we're
programmed. Our biology, I forget
where I heard this, but, uh,
our whole evolutionary process
is about picking the, uh,
the easiest lane and
staying in that lane course.
Once we find something that works for us.
You keep doing it until it's been totally
exploited and no longer works for you.
And then you move onto the next thing.
And for, from a survival standpoint, I do,
I'm thinking about what it
used to be like to be a human
great. When we're all, you know,
hunter gatherer is not so great when
there's 7 billion of us and all of our
decisions are so interconnected that
me deciding to be a a, you know,
a selfish asshole actually
does impact other people.
Whereas a hundred thousand years ago I
could probably plug as many apples from
the trees I wanted.
It would have no impact.
Yeah, it's, it's definitely
getting stranger and stranger.
And we're also eliminating
by use of technology.
We're eliminating a lot of work.
There's a lot of things that you don't
have to do physically that are done for
you acquiring food. Your water comes
at the turn of a nozzle, you know,
your heat is just a button away.
I'll go, I'll go even further than
that on you. Uh, the number of you,
the number of things that we need money
to acquire is actually decreasing every
year.
So I think a lot of people in this kind
of like post recession America feel like
they don't have as much as they
should have, which is 100% justified.
People got fucked.
But uh,
the fact of the matter
is to go on Youtube,
on your iPad and instantly view the
best cooking instructional videos in the
world or the best yoga videos,
any topic you want to about the,
probably the best brain surgery videos,
all those topics are free.
Whereas 10 or 15 years ago it would
cost you thousands of dollars for an
encyclopedia Britannica subscription and
that would only contain a fraction of
the information on Youtube,
the best podcasts in the world,
like years of free people
are accessing them,
paying nothing for this content
that to get it. And you know,
15 years ago,
this kind of content would probably be
a premium cable channel and you'd pay 15
or $20 a month for it. So all these
things are just becoming free.
That's the whole Internet business
model and it's going to get to the point
where you just don't need to pay
for most of the things in your life.
So college will fade away.
You'll just self-educate online and meet
up once a week with other likeminded
people. How we get lid, how you get laid.
It's very hard to get laid
when you're 18 and 19.
You got to be holed up in a house with
people and start dorm rooms. Yeah,
he got to get people confused.
Including yourself. Yeah,
I think you're right. I think you're
absolutely right and I think, um, we are,
we are entering into a new era and it's
a new era of convergence and this new
era, what the government can
do now with this NSA shit,
we're all going to be able to do to each
other and we have to realize that that
is coming.
God dammit,
you're not going to have any secrets
from me and I'm not going to have any
secrets from you. And ultimately
I think it is a beautiful thing.
It sounds fucked up,
but I think it's a beautiful,
that's called radical.
I think it's called radical
transparency of this dude David Brin.
I had him on my show and
he wrote the post man,
which is that book that Kevin Costner
turned into a movie, which was awesome.
I thought it was good. A lot of
people didn't like it was horrible.
I thought it was cool. Oh my god, it
was apocalyptic. Really. It was so bad.
It was great. It's like waterworld on
waterworld on the land. Yeah, I liked it.
Well, you must have had a really
good experience when you watch it,
watch it with a really pretty girl who
was smelled good. Two fingers deep.
Easy man. Easy. We're talking
about love over here. Yeah,
so this Guy Brin talks
about radical transparency,
which is eventually everything will
be known by everyone like this.
That's what I think it means and
that's, that's, that's real man.
You're talking about. I feel that.
I feel that when I get high, I do.
Sometimes when I get high,
it sounds so stupid,
but when I get really stupid
high and I'm just alone thinking,
that's what I think of.
I think of the,
I feel like we are just a few months away.
It seems like,
I know maybe it's a years,
but I feel like we are just a few months
away from everybody hitting some new
level of understanding. Yeah. And each
other. Have you noticed that everything
is speeding up and I feel like the,
even the rate, why don't you get up
Brian? You panic. The rate of, uh,
the rate of these disclosures about
what the government is doing now.
It's like everyday there's
a new braking leak.
It's not like it used to be where there's,
you know,
every now and then some big story every
day there's something huge in the news.
Look at Turkey where you have a young
tech savvy population getting sick of this
guy who is trying to clamp down,
you know, he's saying, all right,
we've got to ban alcohol and we have to
a limit and get rid of public affection
in public places. No more holding hands
or kissing. And the young people who,
who spent their whole life on the
internet, it's like, fuck this dude,
let's all go out and protest. And that's
what you're seeing in Turkey right now.
It's insane. Yeah. It's
uh, it's not just Turkey.
Do you see Brazil? Yeah.
Brazil in Sao Paulo.
Brazil is taking the Brazilian photos.
Look at those photos. Look up there,
Jesus,
man.
And why can't we get even get 20 people
out to an NDA protest in front of us
Federal Court House Week and we're soft.
We're like those people that we
were talking about, we're like,
we're like the spoiled kids,
the kids in the Khakis and where
the people that didn't earn this,
we're not the same people that
fought in World War II. Okay.
It's a different group group of
humans. They, they, those were
gritty survivors that just dug their
fucking heels in and got shit done.
And they were scared. They had
just gotten off of the depression.
They just gotten off of people waiting
in soup lines and people just got shit
done. And there was a lot of bad
to that too though, man. That,
that sort of like desperado
society creates a lot of assholes,
you know,
creates a lot of mean motherfuckers that
do whatever they gotta do to get by.
I don't think that's
necessarily necessary either.
There was a guy sitting next to me
earlier today at this restaurant bar.
I was at getting lunch and he asked to
see like a menu and he asked for the
price of like a sprite or coke.
He was for a sprite.
I think I gave him the price and
you're like, side. He's like,
and then he was asking if there's
anything cheaper on the menu. He was like,
is there anything else? Is it,
uh, and I was thinking if you're,
if you're in that kind of place, you
should try to find a job and like, ha ha,
you know, at least $20 stored up before
you walk into a restaurant to get lunch.
And I feel like there are a lot of
people who just are not putting in a full
effort.
Well, there's that and there's also that
the amount of jobs available today are
shockingly low and they're not, they're
not good jobs. Our time bullshit.
But I think that,
and this is very easy for me to say,
obviously I recognize this
a hundred percent so I
apologize before I even say it,
but I think that with
desperation comes innovation.
And I think when you're in a situation
where you don't know what the fuck to do,
your mind will scramble and you will try
to figure out a better way to live your
life. Whether it's start your own
business, whether it's, you know,
do something innovative, do
something, come up with an idea.
But through desperation,
many incredible ideas have been started.
And so many great people have stories
where they talk about rock bottom.
They were fucking eating ketchup
sandwiches in their shitty one bedroom
apartment and then they went fucking
crazy and created a business.
Whatever it is that takes you to figure
out how to find your place in the world.
Understand this, it's difficult. It's
going to be puzzling along the way.
You gonna to not know
whether you go left or right,
whether you should sacrifice your
morals for performance or for success.
There's going to be moments where you,
you don't know what to do and what
not to do, but you can get through it.
Other people have, other people have
been poor and then not been poor anymore.
Other people been miserable and
then figured out a way to be happy.
Other people have been lonely and figured
out a way to be loved and to be worth
being loved, you know, which is
like step one. It's possible,
but it's not fucking easy.
And the government's not
helping. That's the problem.
We don't have any real leaders.
Well we have as a bunch of people
that decide what we can't do. Also
venting innovation because you
talked about that desperation,
how it breeds people that come with the
right solution that's actually happening.
And you look at all the innovation
in terms of people are like,
this Federal Reserve stuff is bullshit.
Doesn't make sense anymore for us to do
things in this way. So you have bitcoin,
uh, is created a few years ago and other
digital currencies and the government
instead of stepping back, which is
what the Economist magazine, uh,
and an editorial said that the government
should do is just leave this alone,
let it grow for a little while. This
could be the next, uh, you know,
in the same way that American made a lot
of money off the Internet in the 90s,
digital currency could be the
next boom or at least one of them.
And instead of allowing this thing
to grow and see what comes out of it,
they're already cracking down big time.
Now what did they cracking down on and
is there any justification for that
cracking down? Like is it,
they're completely unregulated.
So is it open for the scammers?
There's so many laws on the books in terms
of financial stuff that if you're not
one of the big three banks,
they can throw anything at you
until you run out of money.
So in the bit coin example,
they want after homeland security,
which this is not a terrorist thing.
So I'm not really sure why it's there.
You know,
concern anyway.
But a bunch of nerds trading digital
currency is not a threat to the United
States.
And Homeland Security froze the account.
That was one of the big exchanges
accounts in the United States,
their wells Fargo account,
they froze it,
which is like just freezing part of
that network to get money in and out of
bitcoin.
So bitcoin is still fine because there
are other providers who don't have as
much of a US footprint,
but the fact that they're even doing
that shit means that they are concerned
about it. And instead they should be
doing the opposite. She'd be like,
we're going to give grants,
government grants to startups that are
exploring digital currency cause this
could be the future of the world.
And I'd rather see America be the ones
to create it instead of it being created
in Europe as the cases with
bitcoin being created in Japan, uh,
we're losing out on this
one. We were losing out with
stem cells where, you know,
under Bush we got all this retarded
stuff about not exploring stem cells.
And so other countries just,
we're like, we'll do it.
And now if you're a wealthy American and
you want to get some kind of stem cell
operation,
from what I understand that you have
to fly to one of these other countries.
Germany. Yeah. Germany. Okay.
Cause we don't have a wife
just got back from Germany.
He's telling me how awesome this
Koby Bryant went there and then
money that the u s is losing
out on us jobs. You know,
it's fucked up just because our government
is acting in this regressive way
instead of
what we're supposed to be about,
which is entrepreneurship. And uh,
that's where the big, the
big thing becomes like what
we're supposed to be about.
Hey, be careful. Don't spill it on your
generic laptop. That's not an apple.
What are you talking about?
This is an apple.
It's a TV show that we duct taped it.
Duct tape brand what's called Greeking
cause you make it so that it's
indecipherable.
Is that because uh,
apple will want money or
maybe the other way around.
Like Sony won't want to give us
money. Right. Shows with the TV shows.
I loop my brother. Yeah. For the, the
TV show. I have to do that. You, Oh,
I'll ask you afterwards.
Official Shit.
I almost forgot we were on TV or on the
internet or something. Whenever we are.
Um, all this stuff that you, you say like,
I know that you're not
like a cynical person,
which is like really hard
for people to believe.
If you listen to all the things you
say. I'm super optimistic. Yeah.
Isn't that crazy?
I wrote an ebook about,
uh,
how our is like actually a really positive
one and even this stuff that I talk
about now, they're just road bumps on
the way to what is going to be complete.
I think probably complete abundance.
We had to get through Nixon
to get to Clinton. Right?
I think Clinton was a high point for
this country. I really do. You know,
for theirs there was certainly a lot
of fuckery going on during the Clinton
administration and there was some,
you know,
it's not to say that
people didn't die or there,
there weren't operations that
went on that I'm sure you were,
I wouldn't have approved of. But other
than that, it was a time of prosperity.
And it seemed like a time where everything
seemed like it was going to be okay.
And something happened during the Bush
administration where everything went dark
and it didn't feel like it
was going to be okay at all.
And my perception of America and the
world itself changed radically from the
1990s to the the two thousands it was
a totally different world when in the
1990s the biggest dilemma was that they
wanted to impeach Clinton because he got
hit
right.
It was hilarious.
And there were articles in Time magazine
about how people have too much money.
We're creating too many.com millionaires.
What do we do with this is amazing.
And that was our problem is that,
you know,
real estate prices in
the valley are too high.
What are we going to do as a country?
And that people were buying a house and
then selling it six months later for
twice what they bought it for. It
was just, it was Cuckoo, you know,
and Vladimir Putin, I remember this
quote that he said, he said, uh,
I don't understand the American economy.
They seem to just buy and
sell each other's houses.
I mean it's true for what? A
shitty accent. That was nice.
We're not calling me out.
I saw this on reddit and Soviet Russia,
internet browsers.
You or no,
it was in Soviet America cause
they're making fun of the NSA program.
Oh that's funny.
Yeah
and funnier because it's so true.
It is what it is.
We become exactly what we thought
they were doing it spying on all their
citizens,
trying to prevent the scent because they
lived in a shit hole country and they
didn't want freedom or they
didn't want them to get freedom.
That's what we always felt about Russia.
That was always our jab about Russia.
Fox. You seen the Steve Wasniak video? No,
you guys got to pull that up. What is it?
Pull it up.
He was in an airport and the
Spanish language reporters
came up to him for their
blog or whatever, and they were
asking about the NSA program.
And I think about just like the
future of America. And he talks about,
I don't want to quote him exactly,
but he talks about how America has kind
of lost its way and how we're becoming
more like Soviet Russia. And for him to
say that because he's a super positive,
like sweet dude, cofounder
of Apple, insanely rich,
but still so down to earth that he'll
talk to anybody. That's just the video.
Right.
And that's the video,
like that kind of gray or there
I think, I think I like all
the visuals work. Yup. Yeah,
he's talking about a phone first.
It gets into
party apps and things like
that. So really great to do
other countries when they got
cruiser in a war, they culture,
but we Americans did portrait, we're
good food and all the and everything.
And I was so proud of my country,
you know?
And now I find out it's just the opposite,
And I just wished all these things I
talked about the constitution that made us
so good as people.
They're kind of nothing.
They all dissolve with the Patriot
Act, you know, and there's just laws,
laws that say we can just sort of
secretly call anything terrorism and do
anything but walk it out, all these
rights courts to get in and take care.
I'm doing the wrong things,
not even free open court anymore.
And he read the Constitution.
I don't know all this stuff.
So clear what the constitution says.
Extremely clear in the bill of rights.
One thing after another,
after another that just that overturned
and that's what it came down.
He just goes out. Has anyone rounded
up and killed, keep the prison.
When I was brought up, we were
taught that communist Russia was the,
the ones that were going
to kill us and Bob,
mark country and all this and communist
Russia was so bad because they followed
their people that they swooped on them.
So they, uh, they, they arrested them,
they put them in secret prisons,
they disappeared them.
These kinds of things were part of Russia.
Yeah. Kind of breaks your heart, right?
Cause this is the guy who made it in
America based on what we believe in.
And now he's in an airport,
he's middle aged and he's seeing that
this revolution that he was a part of the
technology revolution is
being used against people
instead of being used to help
people.
We have a real problem with
the leadership of this world.
And when I say this world that I don't
mean in any sort of new world order sense.
I mean leadership across the board,
every single country,
everywhere you go, every single
leader of every single nation,
we don't have a leadership that fits in
with the psychedelic nature of 2013 and
when I say psychedelic nature,
I don't even mean drugs.
I mean the idea behind psychedelics,
when someone talks about having a
psychedelic experience and oh my God,
it was like a psychedelic trip.
What they mean besides the, uh,
the hallucination aspect is that
this trip has transcended them,
has moved them into this new place,
has made them step back and look at it.
It could be a near death experience.
It could be the loss of a friend.
It could be a pet dying,
it could be a new,
you're getting fired
and getting a new job.
There's many things in life you could see
a starlit night and it's a psychedelic
experience
that that is where we're going.
Where we're going is newer booms,
newer woes,
newer connections,
new understandings,
newer uncoverings of hidden
truths and and, and we're,
we're getting closer and closer to each
other and what the government is doing
is the exact opposite of that.
What they're trying to do is control,
get people scared.
Control resources dictate their
rules on as many people as possible.
Make it so they can't be prosecuted for
the same thing they actually prosecute
people for but never be
called hypocritical control.
All the resources control what they're
doing is non psychedelic with they're
doing is what the ego does when
it's desperate, when it's sad,
when you're trying to cover up for a lie,
when you're trying to,
you're trying to attend, you're something,
you're not dealing with mortality.
You know, if you think you need
complete control over other people,
that's some kind of
weird foil to get around.
The fact that you're
gonna be dead in 30 years.
Our society needs to be psychedelic.
And I don't say that in the
way that a lot of people think.
A lot of people think when
you say something should be
psychedelic like a little
bit, you just want to escape reality.
Fucking hippie. That's not what I mean.
I went, I mean embrace reality, embrace
reality in its broadest sense possible.
And it's brought a sense possible.
We are all exactly the same.
And that me, I don't mean that
in any hippie sort of a way.
I mean that we are temporary beings
on this strange course that no one
understands and we all have a certain
amount of years to recognize that we're on
this thing and then this thing's going
to end and W it's going to end badly.
The body's gonna stop working. There
was a sales will reproduce incorrectly.
You're going to cheat. Your stature
changed your, your health fades,
your energy wanes. Intellect goes away.
It goes away the child. And then you die.
So during that time we have
to figure out what is this,
what is this and what
are we trying to do here?
And if what you're trying to do is control
resources and down AP people and make
as much money as possible,
you are just as sad as some kid is
born in Ethiopia where there's no food.
You're just as sad as someone who is on
an island that doesn't have any books.
It's all a mis.
It's all a mess.
And the Psychedelic Society of 2013
that transcendent experience of the
Internet,
the ability to communicate with each
other from long distances instantaneously.
That's very psychedelic
interview with one of the engineers at
Google who a overseas youtube and just
the process of a youtube video uploading
and then propagating on all their cache
servers is a,
it's kind of psychedelic in the sense
that within seconds of your video being
uploaded less than that,
like immediately,
it's on servers all over the
planet because when you, uh,
when you go to a youtube video,
it's serving you the video from a
server that's relatively close to you.
And maybe one in California or something.
Uh,
somebody in South America is getting a
local version of their youtube video and
then all the data on the hits from
each of those local servers is coming
together. And that's the youtube view
counter how many hits the video has.
So it's actually coming from all
these different data centers.
There's not one number, it's a bunch of
numbers that are being, uh, you know,
put together. And just the
way he explained it as like,
this is fucking insane.
You know, like that somebody in their,
in their basement like, uh, uh, you know,
the big famous video bloggers out
there can put up their video and within
seconds it's literally all over the world.
And if that idea has any kind of value,
it propagates within hours like that.
Edward Snowden video,
uh,
was on the homepage of youtube because
so many people found it to be significant
rose right to the top.
I think we are going to have
to accept a new paradigm,
including the government
and the government's trying
to stave off that paradigm
by creating a bunch of rules.
And by taking away people's rights,
but they're not going to be able to,
by having so many rules that you
can selectively enforce it. Yeah.
Like I'm sure this stuff they're using
against Bitcoin, they're not using against
Bank of America or
Citibank. Yeah. Well the,
the selective enforcement aspect of it is,
it's,
it's funny because what they're trying to
do as I can trying to control judgment,
they're kind of trying to control the,
the,
the will of the people that
trying to control, you know,
the popular opinion they're trying to,
they're trying to control human beings
as a resource because all the power comes
through the human beings. It all
flows from the money, from the taxes,
from the votes,
from the whatever that you get into a
position of power and you're the top of
that pyramid.
Then you can enforce regulations and
rules and change things and you could do
things that people never want.
Like the NDA when you,
all of a sudden you have
indefinite detention and
people don't even get lawyers
and you're like, what? The Russian
doesn't even do that. I think, uh,
one of my do they, they might, I
don't know enough about Russia.
They probably would do that. I just know
that our t is filled with nice people.
They are very nice.
Isn't that weird?
It's like you would think Russia today
would be like the shittiest bunch of
assholes and, but he could do,
they suck. They're all severe.
Super Nice. Uh, yeah. I forgot what I was
gonna say. Let's think about Russia today,
but, uh, it, uh, where are
we talking about here? Um,
we were talking about the
monarch. Oh yeah. I know that.
But um, it'll come to me.
I had the specific idea about something.
Oh, okay. It's all this Jamison.
It's kind of,
yeah. Was going to my brand
whiskey is not good for the dome.
The government lacks it.
Don't they tried to take that away.
Then there'll be the real riots of me.
That's what it really,
we really need to take away liquor, liquor
and cigarettes. Make it all illegal.
Yeah.
Hey, hey, calm down. Oh, I'm saying I
remember what, I have a real revolution.
I remember I was going to
say, sorry about that. Uh,
I have this kind of science
fiction dystopian view that
when the NDA was signed
and you know, I was vocal about
this nonstop, when that was signed,
that was one of these like branches or
forks in history where we should have all
come out.
We should have all came out and protested
and people who had positions of power,
you know,
TV anchors and senators who
are not compromised by their
own parties should have
said, this is fucking bullshit.
Since when can you PR in prison,
American citizens without a trial
on the basis of suspicion alone.
That's fundamentally UNAMERICAN it,
it makes North Korea look like on
the same level as us to do that shit.
Why would we allow that? This needs
to be immediately fixed. You know,
like next week we need an amendment to
fix whatever the you did on New Year's
Eve.
But instead life just kind of went on as
normal and it was like a twilight zone
episode.
You know,
I noticed this group of activists and
journalists have raised money and they
went to New York to fight this shit
in federal court and they could barely
afford the legal and the travel costs
and they're fighting the most powerful
government on earth in court, which can
keep throwing money at this forever.
And that's when I started to lose
faith in the system. Cause I'm like,
well why are they doing this?
You know,
Obama had the signing statement
saying that he, he signed it into law,
but he doesn't like this provision.
He doesn't trust that provision.
Well then why do you keep
fighting for that right in court.
If you don't want that and you signed
it away and you're signing statement,
then why do you keep fighting
for it in federal court?
And at that point I was like,
this is, this is fucked.
I think it's again, what we keep saying.
Why do you, why does he, why do you,
I don't, I don't think it's a
you. I don't think it's a, Hey,
well then I don't think anybody,
but we have to.
Anybody gets any of the real power him
somewhere. I mean, we certainly do.
If you go to a wall,
it's like a corporation type blame.
Well that's valid though.
If you go to a Walmart and you slip on
the floor because the floor is dirty and
wet,
you write a letter to the CEO,
even though he wasn't personally
there to mop that floor.
And the same way Obama is the figurehead
for this federal government and its
current form.
So if we can't place the blame there,
if we can't petition him to make
things better, who can we petition?
Well, that's a good question,
but I think that it's in,
and it's impossible at this point in
the game to control the whole thing.
There's no,
there's no way.
There's no way he could have his
fingers in every hole in the dike.
There's just too much going on.
That's not what I'm at
right after I said it. I'm like,
fuck. Um, there's, there's,
there's no way.
And I think the idea that he's responsible
for everything the government does,
it's preposterous, right? Because
there's no way you could be.
There's no way you could.
There's no way you could have a handle
on all that shit. There's no way.
There's too many things going on. You've
got the FBI, the NSA, the DEA, the FBI,
the Coast Guard, the air force, the
army, the marines, the navy seals,
the green berets come on
the rangers. You, you,
you don't know what the
fuck everybody's doing.
You can know what the fuck
everybody's doing. It's ridiculous.
The idea that we have an Obama in the
first place, that we have a president,
that we have one dude. This is the
Alpha male chimpanzee bullshit.
We have a human being that we spend
hundreds of millions of dollars of our
collective taxpayer money to fly that
person somewhere else with 14 limousines
and bulletproof glass everywhere.
It's like a,
some kind of fetishization
of a personality. You know,
it's one thing to have celebrities
because at the end of the day,
at the end of the day, celebrities
are chosen by us. You know?
That's what it comes down to is we
choose who we want to focus and unhealthy
amount of attention on like the
Kardashians. Collectively we choose that.
But how many people are actively choosing
to pay for somebody like Obama or by
the way, President Bush took
expensive vacations also. Uh,
who exactly decided that this kind of
imperial we have now where your vesting so
much power in that one person and yet
like you said, this makes a lot of sense.
That person doesn't have all that much
influence to actually change course.
So then why are we treating them like
they're a god? Because it's a figurehead.
It's a
someone that you, you have with
the head of your organization.
We still as chimpanzees,
you know,
or as the descendants or the ancestors
or whatever the fuck we are, the, the,
the new breed of how fucking ape,
how do we get past the
chimpanzees and to that thing?
I think we needed mushrooms.
I really do. It sounds like,
you know, it sounds like hippie nonsense,
but I really think just logically,
if it's not mushrooms, we need
something that brings us all together.
It might be ecstasy.
One of my most profound psychedelic
experiences I ever had was on ecstasy.
And I only did it once because the,
uh,
the rebound of it was way too
strong the next day. I can't,
I can't refer a crash the next day.
It was horrible. It was horrible.
And I don't know if it's just me or if
it was mixed with something or whatever
it was.
Do any PR like pills with it,
like five HTP or anything
cause you won't have that.
You just had a really bad
experience because you didn't creed,
planet and Post Planet.
Yeah,
I took two pills too.
I think you're only supposed to take one
the first time you do it and whatever.
What,
but whatever the point is,
it was profound and it made
me understand a lot about, um,
about insecurities,
mine and other peoples about
love and about what's possible.
If you're warm, you know, the, the,
the warmth and friend
friendliness and happiness,
that that shit is contagious
and it spreads and good,
good energy spreads just as easily as
bad energy does. But good energy is,
it's way better.
It's way better for you.
It feels better and it's possible
for anyone to change in midstream.
It's possible for anyone to just start
slowly adjusting their life into a more
harmonious path. And that includes
all the people that are running shit.
And guess what?
Along the way,
a lot of you motherfuckers are probably
going to wind up getting busted doing
something stupid. You know,
there's probably a lot of
people right now that are,
that have like gambling
problems or you know,
prostitution problems or you know x fill
in the blank that it's all gonna come
to light. All of it's going to come
to light. There's no way to avoid it.
But I think ultimately it's the,
the best thing for everybody
that we are moving in a way,
and this is very science fiction utopian,
but we're moving in a way where
we're going to merge consciousness.
That seems to me to be the only
step that's at the end of this path.
If you look at what's going on,
the complete lack of privacy that we now
have in regards to the way we interface
with the government.
The government can check your emails,
the government can check, your tax,
government could check a Twitter,
and I think eventually you and I
are going to have that same issue.
We all going to be able to access
all of each other's emails.
We're all going to be able to contact
each other. We're all going to be able to,
what comes after that?
Well,
the only thing that comes after that
is some sort of a convergence of
consciousness.
It's going to be whether it's
technologically created or whether it's
biologically induced as the next step
in evolution. Whatever the fuck it is.
It seems like that's where it's going.
I mean, otherwise what does it do?
It just stops
and let's be all in
plug. I mean, none of us.
That's the one thing that we're not
the worst to have his cell phone.
We're not forced to do any of this.
We could just like a seriously turn off
her phone and then we're off the map.
I honestly,
yeah,
I think the only thing that would get
more than a few random Weirdos to unplug
is a cataclysmic disaster. Something
that wipes out cell phone signals,
a massive solar flare that torches every
satellite makes a start from scratch,
whatever it is,
something that fries every fucking
electrical system all over the globe.
I've had a Weirdos contact
me and they're like, uh,
I would like to share your stuff,
but I don't use Facebook because of the,
you know, they track you and I'm
like, oh well you can, you know,
you can post it on Twitter I
guess, or whatever. I was like,
why don't use Twitter either.
Like you could post on message boards,
like why use tor encryption
or I use the tor browser.
I don't like to go to websites too
frequently. Then just don't fucking live.
You know? Like if you're going
to be that paranoid. Yeah.
You think that Twitter and Facebook
are concerned about everything you're
posting? Well not only
that, you have no influence.
Your just the nobody in the forest. And
Are you doing shady shit? 24, seven.
You know the government,
if you want to beat off to,
I'm going to offer the
government something.
If you want to beat off the same websites,
I beat off to look at my history.
Okay, go ahead. I'm not doing anything
negative. I'm not fighting the power.
Hoo Hoo. I got, I do beat off a lot. Fed
is up a porn. You got to check out man,
uh, getting Dick for their first
time. Oh my God, it's great.
And I was talking to this lesbian
the other day and she's like, yeah,
I broke up with like this girl that was
in a relationship for a long time and I
went right to having Dick,
you know, for like a month.
[inaudible] mean like lesbian.
Do you mean a strap on or like a Dick?
Like she decided to fuck a guy that
she was friends with. What happened?
And she says it was great,
but you know,
if she's back into lesbian now because
whatever for whatever reasons. But I've,
so I've been looking at porn,
you know,
like lesbian gets first dick ever and
it's just like the butch dykes and they're
just like, what the fuck? This is amazing.
It's great. It's good. It's a good,
I knew a search for the
first time. Yeah. Yeah.
I think they're all in denial.
All you girls out there that say you
don't like Dick when I never had deck.
And that's how they all are having
had the right one yet. I feel
I have a joke in my act about that.
About how no guy see two girls work
in that working out. Okay, stop.
I quit jokes over.
No Guy sees two girls making out and
says, aw, too bad they don't like dudes.
Guys don't think like,
like
that. You Go, I just gotta get in there.
We just get closer while we're, uh,
while we're talking about Dicks,
there is a funny story on reddit recently,
how,
you know how you always say powerful and
now it's like everybody uses powerful.
Yeah, it's like this. And he stole that
from my friend Larry. By
the way. Everybody is,
I think Verizon uses powerful
now in their ad campaigns.
They should send you a royalty
checks. But, uh, so people,
people take up other people's phrases,
people say powerful now because of
what you say. Right. And on Reddit,
this guy was complaining
that his college roommate,
I was one of those people who's like,
just absorbs all this social stuff around
him and uses other people's phrases
like immediately and just adopts
their personality. So as a prank,
they play it on this guy. They started
off saying, Dick in my ass, whenever,
whenever something bad would
happen or they would lose it halo.
And within like within a week,
this guy is showing up to this class
late and yelling like Dick in my ass.
Like I knew I should have
showed up earlier. And I'm like,
just saying it all the time.
Oh my God. That's hilarious.
Then it was a plot.
Yeah.
It was this carefully orchestrated
test that's so rude and mean.
Oh, the poor guy. But he feels
devastated. That's great.
And knowing that he was played like that.
That's so common though,
if you're insecure. Especially when
I was, uh, when I was really young,
I had a Boston accent and they
didn't live in Boston that long.
I lived in Boston from the time
I was 13 till I was like 24.
But I had a Boston accent and I didn't
realize it until I heard myself on TV.
I was 19. I heard myself on TV
just getting interviewed. And, uh,
it was like, God, we've been working
really had, I was like, oh no.
I realized that I wanted to be
like everybody else so badly.
I started talking like,
well, it's also very strong. It's like
shit in a pool on that. So, you know,
it's just going to stick really.
But I moved there when I was 13,
so six years later I have a stupid
accent. That's ridiculous. No,
it was a sheep man. I was scared. I
wanted to be like everybody around me.
I wanted to fit right in, you know, uh,
how they used to talk weird and
like the forties and 50s. Oh yeah.
St The don draper of coping
really well. How'd they talk? Uh,
give me an example. Like the
admin voice, like a, you know,
like on the battle front tonight, like
Blah Blah Blah, you know, very official.
I mean in the media they did that like
anchors and actors and actresses to,
I would like to know what you
talked like in real life though.
I read this recently,
apparently that accent is called,
it's either called the Trans Atlantic or
the trans continental accent and it was
not actually used by Americans back then.
It was something,
it was taught in boarding school. It was
considered like the proper way to speak.
So if you were a TV anchor or a famous
actor, you would use that onset.
But Americans back then spoke like us,
which blows my mind.
What I thought that they
all talk, like, you know,
like mad men or not mad at him
like the 20 years before that,
I thought that was real.
But that's just the way they,
the way they talk on TV and on radio.
And then when they're offset,
they're talking like us.
Is there any documentaries or I want to,
you don't want to fact check
this one to get more info,
but I'm pretty certain I'm right on this.
Is there any
be awesome if we saw a reality show from
the 30s like could you imagine jersey
shore from the 30s
no, I can't actually ride
around a model t's right.
Fucking,
you know,
I mean just to imagine what it would
have been like to be around some people
that just survived.
Let's the main question tonight.
That's why I like to watch boardwalk
empire cause you're seeing a,
I mean it's probably glamorized obviously,
but yeah,
it's just entertaining as hell
to see people. Yeah. Period.
That's a brilliant show.
But it is probably glamorized.
That's the problem with the,
anything in regards to the history,
there's so much guesswork.
There's so much. Uh,
it would be really cool to
watch a documentary about
some people that lived in
the 1930s and just, just to follow
them around. But then again,
how comfortable would they be on camera?
That's the real issue.
You would have to experience it yourself.
Yeah.
It's hard to reach back into your
memory and have an accurate account of
anything more than five or
six years ago. Really. Right.
Uh, yeah. I mean this
is all such new stuff.
Like I saw a black and white photo set
of these guys getting there after work
drinks at some pub in, uh, in England.
And so that to me was,
it seemed like an accurate picture
of what was happening then.
Cause you see that these dudes
are just drinking after work.
No cell phones on the table.
No bullshit.
Just like average w because you
don't have any technology back then.
And you could see that
their clothes were not as,
like not as polished as you seen
all the movies from that era.
You could see like, you know,
tatters and stuff. You're like, oh,
they're actually living through
a pretty tough time. You know,
you can see that without the, the gloss
that's been applied to other shows.
Yeah. Um, it's, it's
still, it's like if you,
if you could go back and live in a time
like that, I would love to do that.
What would you really,
especially if you can pick an era,
especially knowing which companies we're
going to take off, but uh, oh no, no, no,
you can't do that.
That's illegal.
I would love to live in 1920s even
the 1930s as long as you're not.
And one of the, you know, poor families,
if you're doing well in the 30s
they did better than anybody.
Yeah. But you would be faced with
so much despair. You'd be sad.
I think they looked around
and saw all the people
they coordinate themselves off from that.
And the same way that we would be cool
with that. Not saying I'd be cool with it,
but look at the fact that, you
know, when this iPhone dies,
it's going to be picked apart by some
child and you know, somewhere in India,
some trash heap for the
precious metals inside it.
We still have all that same shit.
It's just been distanced from us.
And I think people back
then had an amazing life if
they are in a certain social
strata.
This is 1939
color footage, which is very rare
for that, for that year. Wow.
That girl was hot.
She was bawling and 39 isn't it funny
that like that is like someone who's
probably like four feet tall now
arched over and it's almost over,
but she's creeping, creeping around.
I don't know. It might not be,
might be a crypt keeper now.
Five.
It's unbelievable. It's like we just,
we have a short amount of time here.
I think about how weird it is that
all those people smoked constantly.
So even like the hottest girl you'd hook
up with somebody who's smoking a couple
packs a day has like lines all over their
face from just nonstop smoking all the
time.
Have you ever met someone and uh,
then you saw them in like five years
and it was like a hundred years had gone
by. Some people do not age well. Oh,
well if someone gets on Meth,
that's the big one.
I've seen the alcohol.
Yeah,
I guess I like to tell myself
that I think preserving,
preserving my body alcohol is,
that's what I like to tell myself.
It might be in a way because he relaxed
a little bit and maybe you feel a little
bit more positive energy
and that counteracts all
the continents in the world.
Right? You know, there, there's, there's
definitely some benefit to alcohol,
but you poisoning yourself.
Did you hear that?
I wanted to see if you saw that article
that was on today.com about bulletproof
coffee.
I don't know if you saw that or not.
No, I did not. What did it say? It's bad.
Uh, well they said that, you know,
the reports of putting butter
in your coffee today. Dot Com.
It's a, I, I tweeted it earlier. Uh,
they sit there saying that,
you know, there's no, uh,
evidence that butter in your coffee
does anything but it has more calories.
Here's the actual article, I guess
that's Today. Like NBC today,
I guess.
Well, let me, let me just give you
some input right away. First of all,
coffee caffeine has shown how benefits
shown to have benefits on cognitive
function shown to have obviously obvious
benefits on energy. So there's that.
Then when you take coffee with grass fed
butter and MCT oil and they talk about
the MCT oil here,
what it does is it makes it
a slower digestible thing.
Like it's, it takes a longer
time for your body to process it.
Whereas if you have just like a Venti
Starbucks black that goes like right in
your bloodstream song
didn't have bulletproof coffee.
If you have grass fed butter and MCT oil,
you're going to get a lot more calories
and it's a lot fatter and it's all
blended together and so it will take
hours for your body to digest that as
opposed to just the straight coffee.
I've lost weight using MCT oil.
Mct Oil is very good for, you
know, a debate about that.
If you don't know what it is, it's a
medium chain triglyceride oil and um,
it's the most healthy
aspect of coconut oil.
They take coconut oil and they have some
sort of a process with the centrifuge.
And coconut oil is one of
the best things I've heard.
One of the best oils you can
use to jerk off to. Yeah,
it's supposed to be really good for that.
That's what I hear too. I just here. Um,
so if you're, you know, if you don't
have an issue with cholesterol, um,
I wouldn't think there's anything
wrong with bulletproof coffee,
but if you do have an issue with
cholesterol, you're dealing with,
even though everybody says
it's healthy cholesterol,
we live in a strange world and some
people have like real health problems with
all sorts of things that for other
folks would be no problem whatsoever.
So if you thinking about taking, you
know, um, bulletproof coffee, you know,
look into it, find out what your,
you know, we, where your body's at,
unless you know you're okay. But if, okay,
with high cholesterol foods
or high calorie foods,
the benefit of the bulletproof coffee
recipe is that it takes a longer time for
you to digest it. So basically it
said all the benefits of coffee with,
um,
a slower digestion period.
So there's nothing mystery
mysterious about it. There's
nothing magical about it.
Well, the, the amount that you drink every
day, which is a huge, like Starbucks,
like what does that Trenta
Trenta canister? It's 20 ounces.
So they're saying like each cup of coffee,
just a cup of coffee has about
a hundred to 200 calories in it.
So you're eating a ton of cow.
That's enough.
And that's not including the fat, but
what, what they're including the fat.
That's the whole idea of calories. The
calories come from. Yeah, but I mean,
I'm sorry. Some diets
you, you want it, you're,
you're looking at calories and
fat intake. But uh, and this,
this thing that the claim
here is it that MCT,
because it's faster digesting compared
to other fats is an energy booster.
But there's no evidence in this,
but they're pretty much just saying that,
you know, uh, it, uh, be
mindful of the extra calories.
Don't expect weight loss
or enter any extra energy.
That's not necessarily true
because it really is filling.
And if you take 300 or 400 calories in
the form of bulletproof coffee in the
morning,
you might not eat until one o'clock in
the afternoon and you might feel good.
You might,
you're not feeling depleted because
you're getting all these healthy fats and
MCT oil and grass fed butter.
And that's where it's really important
because grass fed animals are far
healthier than corn fed animals.
And see the difference in the,
the tube steak cuts clearly, and this
is not, this is not hippy bullshit.
If you look at a cut of grass fed Sirloin,
you will see a dark red color.
It looks leaner.
It's a different cut of meat,
like a grass Fed New York strips.
Perfect example cause
very little fat on that.
But if you look at a regular New York
strip from corn fed, you know you're,
you're going to get like this.
It's all more marble. More
pink. Yeah. I mean that's,
it tastes delicious because it's that
fat makes it all juicy and it cooks down,
but it's really not as healthy that
you're not getting as much out of the,
the meat itself. It's not as good for
you. Well that's the same with butter.
You're, you're getting butter
from an animal that's corn fed.
You're going to give this fat,
sloppy,
stupid cow who's shitting out
pus in her milk? You know,
it's the same with a not good for you.
Same with eggs.
I think if you get the regular, the
regular cheap eggs, they have thin shells,
not as much a mega threes versus
the more expensive like cage free.
All these freeze which
you want because they're,
they're roaming around
and they're eating grass.
If you can get a chicken seeding grass,
that's a chicken that's healthy.
But somewhere along the
line somebody figured out,
well we can make more money if we just
stack them in like apartment complexes
and shove all these chickens and these
little boxes and feed him the horse
freedom. The Monsanto
grass. Yeah, it's, you know,
it's unfortunate and that's also
a part of this whole big picture where
people don't want to have to go hunting.
They don't want to have to go kill a bird.
They don't want to raise chickens,
they don't want to raise goats.
We want to be able to go to McDonald's
and they wanted to be able to just give
their money and get their food and be
done with it. And when you have that,
then you're going to have this,
you're going to have a regular person
is not going to be able to just produce
for themselves or for a
small group of people.
They're going to have to produce
for thousands, maybe even millions.
And so when a company or a person or a
business is producing all this food for
millions of people,
and these billions of people can just
pull into these stops with their cars,
which you've got his madness.
Yeah.
We've got this massive
disconnect from responsibility
to make money off of shit that
is that cheap to begin with.
You have to be working with
really cheap materials. Yeah.
So you're cutting costs wherever you can.
I mean, if you're buying a $3 cheeseburger
without fucking what is in that thing,
imagine if someone only paid you $3. Say,
listen man, this one wants you to do,
I want you to shoot a cow and then a take,
ship it across the country,
cut a chunk of meat out of it,
and I want you to grind that meat
and then form it into a patty.
And then I want you to cook it.
And then I want you to put that I would
get some lettuce. You got to get some,
let us go get it.
Go pick the lettuce and then wash
it off and then cut some tomatoes.
And then polo onion on there.
And then I want you to make some ketchup.
And then I want you to make some
mustard and swirl it all around.
And then I want you to cook it and feed
it to me. How much would that cost? $3.
It would be a $100. Look at norms,
man. You have steak and eggs for what?
$7 that Saint Nicholas. But at least
you norms. You sit down, you know,
norms is like, they're trying to be
frugal and it's probably released.
You sit down, right?
This drive through shit.
The craziest thing ever. A cheeseburger
please. Is that it? Yep. That's it.
$2 and 50 cents please.
$2 50 cents. That's crazy.
You give him $2 and 50 cents and then
they eat it and then you go like somehow
or another that cow died.
That bread was cooked,
that's ketchup was manufactured. That
pickle was pickled. It was sliced,
it was slapped on your bond.
It takes
the social out of, uh, out of eating.
I think one of the most fun things to
do is sit down with people that you're
interested in,
have like a nice solid dinner.
Even if it's just a burger or something.
But now you're like in your car
by yourself. You know, you park,
cause you don't wanna be on the highway
while you're trying to down this thing.
You Park your and your car by yourself.
Just eating something like an animal.
It just kind of consume
these just consuming calories
as quickly as possible so
you can get on your way.
Rose are talking about health stuff.
I wanted to ask you about flotation tanks
because I did one in Florida recently
for the first time. Did you
select it? I liked it a lot,
but I didn't get any of the,
the cool visuals that were talked
about on the videos. How far,
how many times did you do it? I
did it for an hour. A One? Yeah,
just once so far toward the end.
Uh,
I saw like kind of like a doll,
white flash on my right side and I
thought that somebody had the tank,
but it was just like me,
I guess fantasizing about the tank
being opened because I knew that it was
around that time. But other than
that, there are no visuals at all.
It's just much visualizations. The first
time I did it. Okay. So that's normal man.
Oh yeah. It's completely normal.
It's hard to relax, you know,
it's a weird environment.
The like the first 1520 minutes,
you just freaking out that
you're in this weird tank.
Well then I could hear my own heartbeat
and feel the blood pumping through my
body. It's pretty weird. It
doesn't feel great though,
and he fly. I explained it in there.
It's like taking myself on a date.
You're just like, they're like,
it's weird to explain to them.
That's a good way to describe it. Nothing
really happened, but at the same time,
the rest of that afternoon was awesome.
Yeah,
everything was bright and I was almost
grateful for stimulation because I'm a
very like very intense
type a kind of person,
so to be in a fucking thing for an hour
and have nothing going on except for my
own thoughts afterwards,
it's like I'm in traffic driving back
from Delray and I'm like, this is great.
I love traffic. You know something to
think about like dodge these other cards,
you know? That's funny. Hallucinate at
all. Joe, during when you were rolfing?
No. What does Ross painful
but you don't loosen.
I hallucinate when it's painful massage.
It's like the time it starts.
The other day I was just like seeing all
this crazy shit and it was so high. No,
I don't like,
I don't like Thai massages.
They put you on the ground
and they stretch you out.
You don't like, I love that.
I love, I like being on a table. The
oil you up, it's nice stretch you out.
It's better for your body.
Like it doesn't feel as good,
but it's better for your body.
Little snail trails everywhere.
It's Ho Hey,
I don't even know what those are.
I don't know if I want to know.
Well you do want to know you and Brian
Hook up after the show. He'll show you.
I'll show you pictures of the NSA is
doubtless already seen. They're starting,
they're going to shut down the program
because they're so repulsed by Brian's
tragic snail trail folders.
17 barf. It's funny, I read that, uh,
like some huge percentage of internet
users put their porn in a file called tax
return. They do like tax returns
2007 and a lot of people do it. So,
so people go, just go
looking, right? So if your,
if your wife or girlfriend is
looking through your computer,
last thing she wants to click on is your
boring tax return so it gets skipped
over. That's funny. A friend of mine
called would just put it under call.
I was like my girlfriend
and go look at golf.
All you have to do is put it in a folder
and change the file extension from a
folder to like a jpeg and call it
something like sample dot jpeg.
And then when you tried to click on it
and nothing will happen because there'll
be an error. And then when
you want to look at your porn,
it can switch it back to switch factor.
Nice. No chicks going to figure that out.
Dude,
you're on a next level CSI shit.
You should really be
working for the NSA dog.
Why are you wasting all your
talent here on podcasts?
Um, is there a way to fix
this Shit, David Seaman? Yeah.
I'm glad you asked that because like
you said, I am a really positive person.
I'm not, I'm not a cynic. I'm not somebody
who, when you're hanging out with me,
I'm complaining about everything.
Cause I think 98%
of human existence and probably like 99%
of human existence in the United States
is amazing. You don't have
access to so much entertainment,
so much cool shit to do
constantly that there's no,
if you're bored and you're over the age
of 18, that's your own fault, you know?
But,
uh,
I was watching this lecture that Glenn
Greenwald gave at Hampshire college and
the videos on Youtube,
that's how I watched it. Uh,
it's like an hour long lecture
and then a Q and a session.
And Glenn Greenwald is the
journalist who initially broke, uh,
this NSA whistleblower story.
He published it in the Guardian and
Glenn Greenwald has been all over civil
rights for like years.
He used to be a lawyer,
so he knows his stuff
and he's super thorough.
And you would think a guy like that
would be really cynical by breaking all
these terrible stories about abuses
at Guantanamo and all this stuff.
But he said in his lecture,
he was like,
the one thing we have to keep in mind
is even the most powerful institutions
throughout human history or just
composed of human beings like you and me.
And it's been shown throughout history,
regardless of the civilization,
that when enough human beings get together
and decide that that institution is
no longer functioning properly and either
needs to be shut down or reformed in
some way, that happens without
exception pretty much, you know,
like that can happen. And we're talking
about these agencies as if they're,
you know,
some monolithic thing is just compose
the people who go home at the end of the
day and want to see their kids and they
want to save up enough money to not work
in a cubicle anymore one day. And, uh,
the people outside of that system just
don't want to be spied on and they don't
want to have this country turn into
East Germany where people no longer do
anything because they're
afraid of the consequences.
Like you look at East Germany,
no great art came out of that
country when it was in lockdown.
A No great inventions that I know of.
And why is that?
It's because everybody just wants to
get by without attracting attention.
And that's not what the United
States should be. We're the,
we're the total opposite of that where
you get as much attention as you want and
hopefully you'll do something valuable
in the process. That's our system.
And if you want more attention than you
deserve, there's a repercussion for that.
Right? Then you get, you get
slammed down by the, you know,
the people who make fun of the
cardiac issues. There's a balance.
But if you get a situation
where the normal person is
now afraid of what they're
saying in their emails and phone calls,
how many months does it take before? Okay,
first of all,
the journalism dries up and then the
protests dry up and then the entrepreneurs
dry up because they go,
I could make this app,
that'll make it easier for
you to pay for your food. Uh,
but I'm a little bit worried about the
government doing what they did to the
bitcoin guys.
So I'm just going to stay at my shitty
job and not develop this incredible app
that could be the next paypal.
And then before you know it,
the u s is no longer this innovative hub
and it's all just happening in Europe
or in fucking New Zealand
where Kim Dotcom is.
And he's the one who's making all the
money off of it because they trust him
more than they trust American
entrepreneurs. And that's not,
why should we go down that road
when that's not our history.
That's not what we believe in. You
know, it's just, I think there's a,
it's total bullshit. Yeah. There's
Ernest Hemingway quote about America.
This is a fine place and
it's worth fighting for. And
I feel that way. You know,
like I was walking around near my hotel
earlier today and the houses in this
neighborhood nearby or not big houses,
they're just modest homes.
Everybody had an American flag out front,
I guess,
cause they're getting
ready for the 4th of July.
Everything was quiet and peaceful.
And people have nice cars, you know,
like nice pickup trucks and stuff.
America's worth fighting for. You know,
like we're a peaceful,
smart, uh, chill people.
We don't need to continue to go down this
road of being afraid of everything and
everything being kept in the dark from us.
Like we're little children
and we can't handle it.
It's really patronizing and it's
not our system. Do you think
that the time of the country is limited?
The time,
the idea of the country and the embracing
the idea of a global civil right.
I, I think we're just getting started.
We're just getting started. Yeah. I mean,
you look at, look at Rome. It's not as if
things stopped and they became imperial.
That's really when the fun
began, you know? I mean,
we have a lot of shit ahead of us and
it's not all going to be bad stuff. Yeah.
It isn't all going to be
bad stuff and I'm, I'm,
I'm wondering how much of that can be
impressed upon the people that are in
power. So it doesn't have to be bad. Like
you can actually run this in a good way.
You fucks,
like someone can come along who has
a enough ideas of how this can be
structured,
where it can be.
The people still get to make money and
people still get to have order and people
still get to have laws and there's
still respect and there's still, but
some people are already doing that.
Uh, I was in Uruguay last year,
fairly small South American country
I think right next to Brazil. And uh,
I was there and their president is
known as like one of the most, uh,
how do you put this like one of the
least selfish presidents of the world and
still like the still the figurehead
for a fairly successful country.
Uh,
so he gives away like 80% of his salary
to charity and t his hobbies instead of
being obsessed with getting
invited to stuff like Bilderberg.
He Gardens with his longterm girlfriend,
they plant flowers,
he drives an old VW beetle. Like
one of the ones from the 70s. Yeah,
he drives an old beetle. And what's funny
is his past is really like a messed up.
He spent I think a decade in a well in
prison as a political prisoner and he had
been shot by police at some
point and all this stuff.
But instead of becoming
radical and becoming this
like anti anti wealth kind of
South American radical, uh, who
wants to seek to get revenge,
he just became a total moderate.
And you know,
he'd gardens and he's the president.
People love him and he looks like,
like what a South American
dictator would look like. You know,
he's like this old jovial white guy,
right?
Instead of going down that path of just
acquiring more and more power, he's like,
fuck it.
Like we're going to have a free country.
And I think that's something that more
and more world leaders could probably
aspire to.
How much of, yeah. I mean,
how much of the direction of civilization
has really dictated by charismatic
individuals? I mean, it's, it's so often
than someone in a right way or wrong way
lead. We'll look at Hitler, Hitler
speeches. I watched this thing.
When you look at Kennedy speech,
I watched this thing where
they subtitled his speeches.
So you could see what it's actually sang
because I've always wondered how could
people go along with this raving
lunatic, right? And be like, yeah, yeah,
we should put the Jews in the
homosexuals and the ovens. You know,
this sounds good. Uh, how
could they go along with this?
The Germans are smart and if you look
at the subtitles of his speeches,
he's saying stuff like,
you know,
when one German needs help
and other German should
reach out because that's what
we're about as a country is you help
out another German who's down, you know,
down on his luck and we move
each other forward together.
All this shit that like, you can see
why people would go along with it.
It wasn't right.
It wasn't craziness.
And then behind the scenes he's doing
all of this really terrible shit. And uh,
so he spoke to the common folk.
Yeah. I guess where I'm going
with this is you're 100% right,
that there are a handful of charismatic
people that have a huge amount of
influence on what direction would
I like to think that in this day and
age that that's changing. I really do.
I like to think that in this day and age,
because we live in this new paradigm and
you and I have accepted it because we
have no vested interest in
keeping the past. You know,
we didn't have any control and you,
he neither you nor I had any control
over the way. The world worked a decade,
two decades ago,
so there's no,
we have no vested interest in
keeping the thing the way it is now.
We recognize that the world is changing.
We recognize that society is changing.
People are fucking smarter,
man. They're smarter,
they're smarter and they're more aware
and they're more tuned in and it's not as
easy to fucking trick on.
You see it with entertainment.
You see it with talk shows.
You see it with the criticism,
criticism of a newspaper,
articles and books and blogs.
People are more tuned in now
than they ever have been before.
Well,
it's funny,
a financial newsletters used to be
really big in the 90s where people would
subscribe to some experts, stock
picks, and he would say, you know,
I'm up 18% for the past
year. Uh, you know, whatever.
And people would subscribe,
thinking, Oh, if I just listened to what
this guy says, I'll make 1800% per year.
And uh,
I almost went to work for a company
earlier this year that reached out to me.
And what they do is they've found a way
to actually audit these people whose
results. So they go, oh, okay,
let's actually see what you've
been buying and selling.
You didn't make 18 per 1800% this year.
You made like 10%.
And so they publish all the results
and people pay for access to that
information.
And so what you're seeing is this one
area that used to be really scammy is now
moving closer and closer to total
transparency where you know,
if you're the real thing and you're
actually picking the right stocks,
then you're going to,
you're going to gain more followers
than you ever would have before because
people see that you're the real
thing and if your bullshit,
nobody's going to go down that road.
And I feel like it'd be great if we
get get that going for other areas of,
than other than stock newsletters, like
let's get going for government agencies,
let's get it going for anything. Like
just show the people the actual numbers,
let them decide for themselves if this
is something that we want to do and if
not,
it'll go away.
It seems like that's what a lot
of people are terrified of. Yeah.
A lot of people are terrified
about having to do that.
Having to rise to the occasion,
having to recognize that we live in a
completely new world and that there's a
lot more competition because there's
a lot more access to the game and
well people say stuff, they're like, well,
should we have that much competition?
And you really, you do want that
because, so like if you have,
that's a funny thing to say,
she'll,
there'll be that much competition will
say things like the stock market is good.
Like it is now being closed
on weekends and stuff.
But ultimately you want total
information exchange at all times.
You'd want 24 seven like
commodities markets. Right.
And so people are like arguing for
this old shit. And you're like,
well why are you arguing for that when
it's less transparent? You just want,
ideally you want people to be able to
do anything at any time as long as it
doesn't harm other people.
Yeah, absolutely. And then includes
online gambling, online porn, online,
anything there.
The idea of regulating human
behavior is completely ridiculous.
If that human behavior doesn't
hurt other people. And if it's not,
then it's about controlling resources.
And if it's about controlling resources,
it becomes about why should one person
be able to tell you what you can and
can't do if you're not in somehow or
another imprisoning or doing something
fucked up to other people. If you're
not, then they shouldn't be that long.
There's just too many.
There's too much.
There's too much business
and enforcing it.
There's too much business and manipulating
words in order to control humans.
And that's what I think
everybody's freaking out
about when it comes to the NDA
or and,
or the Patriot Act.
Well, this, uh, to this section
to 15 of the Patriot Act,
they have a secret interpretation of it
and that's how the NSA is doing all of
this data collection. Or at least that's
the foundation for some of it, I believe.
And uh,
how ludicrous is that?
Like the Patriot Act is scary
enough what it actually says,
but then you have the
government saying, oh no, no,
we have this secret interpretation in a
lock box that you can't actually look at.
But our secret interpretation
allows us to do a, B, and C.
It'd be like if you signed a contract
and then, uh, the guy doesn't pay you.
It had been agreed upon and you take him
to court and you sue them and he's like,
no, you can't sue me because actually
you have a secret interpretation of your,
your compensation on his contract. You'd
be like, that's totally fucking insane.
There's no basis in law for that.
But the government is doing this stuff and
up until, you know, the past few weeks,
people have not really been
calling them out on it. I mean,
of course some people have,
but it hasn't gone mainstream
and the way that it is now.
Yeah. Well you're talking about
everything accelerating, you know, uh,
they're experiencing that now too.
There's experiencing that slowly but
surely. I was like, one, two, three,
four.
When you look at all these amendment,
these whistleblowers, he's like,
what the third or fourth
guy from the NSA alone,
how bad must things be there that you
were willing to give up everything to come
out and talk to the press?
Yeah. Well, there's some people
that feel like they're compelled.
There's real heroes in this world.
You know, like what Pat Tillman did.
I'm that guy a,
he
was the football player.
Yeah.
He was a professional football league
player superstar and decided he wanted to
go and defend this country.
So he risked it all and went
over to Afghanistan or Iraq,
wherever it was killed,
I think it was Afghanistan and uh,
found that it was a big fucking shit pile.
Once he got there,
it was completely disorganized. It was
a mess. And it was very vocal about it.
Some people though that they really will
do with this guy's done and step up and
say, hey, you know,
this needs to be discussed and talked
about and everyone's chasing after him and
everyone is talking about,
and this cover of USA Today,
x percent think he should be
prosecuted and blah, blah blah.
But the bottom line is all the
sudden that dialogue is open,
all of a sudden that
conversation is being had.
Who are these people that are allowed
to read David Seaman's email and why can
they,
aren't they just people?
And Weird things happen when you call
yourself the NSA or the CIA or the FBI.
You know, when you become part of a
group, you can do some weird shit.
Even when you call yourself district
manager, weird stuff happens. Yeah.
You go from like being an objective
observer. But what happened to,
well I can't return more than a certain
percentage of shirts because it'll make
my numbers look bad.
So he had to swing.
He's no longer acting out of total
objective reality and they have a vested
interest in some kind of outcome and you
multiply that times that thousand and
you get the national security
agency. Yeah. But uh,
to go back to being positive and I think
we're headed for a star trek future.
Like if you, if you watch like star Trek,
next generation, not the, the new, uh,
you know, major motion pictures
that are just action flex.
But that whole ideal view that
hundreds of years from now,
people have so much abundance in terms
of energy and information that money is
no longer the focus.
Cause if you want to get an education,
it will be given to you because it
won't cost us that much to do it.
So if you want to get education online.
Yeah, exactly. That's what I mean.
Like you'll get an education,
all the education you need a,
if you need healthcare,
it's going to be so commoditized,
so easy to provide a level of care.
You'll get that.
If you want to fly across the country,
it's going to cost you almost
nothing because one of the big, uh,
costs right now to fly is the jet fuel.
It's not the least of the airplane.
It's not the shitty wages they pay
to the pilot and the stewardess is,
it's actually the jet fuel that's burning.
What about when you,
when we move away from
that, that kind of, uh,
that era and get something better
to power all of our vehicles,
then it changes everything because then
FedEx something across the country,
it doesn't cost much anymore either.
Before you know it,
you have a society where you just don't
have to pay for all that much stuff.
How about this?
How about when it's down to everybody
acquiring raw materials because you have a
three d printer in your house that's
going to know ever has to buy anything
that's going to be absolute
crisis that's coming.
You're going to be able to download the
instructions and the directions for your
laptop. Make your own fleshlight making
anything that's happening too. For sure.
I think it's basically going to
be anything, I think it's going to
start off just like printers were where
you know they were only black and white
and you have to have a big office to
have a laser and it took forever to print
it out. Yeah, I mean it's completely
changed. It's changed radically.
The ability to download an image. I
remember who used to be like click, click,
click, click, click, click. It was like
really slow to get like a, you know,
one megabyte jpeg. Now it's
instantaneous. There's,
there's gonna come a time when everyone
can just get what they want online.
You're going to be able to download the
instructions and people are going to
probably have some sort of a
paypal system or some sort of a,
you know, a, a donation system
where they'll, they'll, hey,
I invented this and they'll upload it and
people donate a bunch of money to them
to, to be able to use it and
they'll find merit in it.
If they find merit in it and
they have the resources, they'll,
they'll upload the money to this person
and that person will be able to benefit
from it.
Yeah. If you live in America, even today,
if you have a truly great idea
and you put it out on, you know,
whatever these sites,
our Indiegogo and Kickstarter,
you can get the money you need to
make your dream a reality. And uh,
that's extraordinary.
That didn't exist until very
recently and it will be a reasonable,
you would pitch a bank and if it wasn't
something they thought would produce a
return and you didn't have the right
credit profile, you'd be denied.
And now you can just
put it on Kickstarter.
Nobody cares about anything
other than is the idea worthy?
Yeah, no doubt. Alex Grey's Kickstarter,
he came on the podcast to
talk about it and um, within,
I don't know, a couple of days, his,
his Kickstarter had gone over $200,000.
That's a beautiful thing.
It's, it's a, it's a,
it's a weird thing that you can
do that today. It's $210,000 now.
And that was like within
days we watched that change.
It's like all people have to do
is be alerted to a good idea.
And then they look at the Kickstarter,
oh, this is a very reasonable offer.
He has all these really cool things that
he's going to give you. He's going to,
he'll draw an image of
you for x amount of money.
He'll give you free tickets
to the opening event.
Theone for this amount of money.
And in doing something like that
and creating something like that,
he essentially like
organized and, and, and, and,
and energized this base of
supporters. And then, you know,
if you have a million fans and the x
amount of them give you money, boom,
you're up and running.
You don't need to sell your diktat Nestle.
You don't need to stick your
ass up in the air for Coca Cola.
You do whatever you want.
You can do whatever you want.
Yeah. It takes away the power from, uh,
the guy was the guy got dinner with last
night as a TV producer and he's friends
with, uh, the guy who
produces Philip defranco show.
And he was one of the
bigger youtube shows.
And he was talking about how now,
like these networks just don't matter
because it's, all they have is like,
they're like,
we've been around for 60 years.
And somebody who started two
years ago, I was like, well,
that doesn't fucking matter anymore if
we're producing better content than we're
actually competitive. And you're seeing
now that location doesn't matter either.
You know, looking at what's his name
is sai or Gangnam style [inaudible]
even though he's not in
like a hotbed of us music,
he instantly took off over here
because of this technology.
We have no watching five Asian,
you're up dance around and looking
weird with hot Asian girls.
But then we hope they don't
get the fuck before we do.
I guess what I'm saying
is if the idea is good,
it propagates now in a way that was
just impossible even 10 years ago.
Oh for sure. You know, I mean, look,
this podcast has never been advertised
anywhere. We haven't done anything.
All we've done is just keep doing it.
And in doing that,
it's built a completely
organic word of mouth. I mean,
I've talked to people about,
if they asked me about it in interviews,
I've done nothing to try to promote this
podcast as far as like commercially and
it sorta just caught on on its own.
And I think honestly,
it'd be a slower road for
someone who's not famous.
But it's possible for
like almost anybody today.
And I know you have a podcast now and by
you putting your ideas out there on the
Internet, you gained a lot of support
when you were going to run for Congress.
And then that support bled over to, you
know, things that I came in contact with.
And then you and I came in contact with
each other and you came on this show and
then you started going on a bunch of
other shows and then they're all sorta of
webs out from each other.
You didn't have any important family
that you came from, you didn't have any,
uh, you know, privileged influence.
Well you had a brother who
was the president of the
night or there was nothing
like that. Well, I think
we're just a guy. It's a,
it's funny because the things that I
thought used to be my weaknesses and this
new environment are actually
your biggest strengths.
Like I was kind of deeply insecure back
when I was a journalist and now I'm a
journalist again because
the congressional thing,
I think that was a little delusional on
my part to think that you can jump in
there and hope to have any kind of
chance, uh, to, to be taken seriously.
But, uh, now that I'm
back to doing journalism,
the things that I used to be really
insecure about that I wasn't working for a
TV network and didn't have, you know,
New York Times or NBC News after my name.
Those are actually your biggest strengths
today because people go, Oh, if,
if this guy knows about something,
he's not going to hold back.
He's going to do the research
and put it out there.
And the other thing that I'm not afraid
to do that I think more journalists
should do is put things into perspective
for people. People are busy, you know,
I sat there reading for this
boring national security
stuff and then I'm able to
pick out what's important
and tell people this matters.
And then sometimes people will tweet me
something that seems like a really big
deal. And I'll debunk it. I'm
like, actually it's problematic,
but it probably doesn't
matter because of a,
B and c and people need that cause
there's no sense of perspective anymore.
You go to the homepage of Yahoo
and it's something about Obama,
some huge meeting with, you know, Merkel
in Germany. And then the next line,
right next to it is Kim Kardashians baby.
And then the line below that is the
Duggar family or the Doug, ours,
whatever they're called, that have 19
kids. The reality TV horse, it's them.
And so it fucks with your
mind cause you're like,
are these things all equally important?
These,
this is what's most important in the
world today are these three stories.
And you need people who are
not compromised by the system,
who have a no paycheck coming directly
from a news organization to just say,
yeah, this is really important.
People should pay attention to it.
Or this is bullshit. It's just being
hyped and it's not that big a deal.
Well essentially there's always going
to be a need for junk food. Yeah.
And there's gonna be a need for
intellectual junk food as well.
And much like actual food. If you
offer people intellectual junk food,
there's a certain group of us and I
lump me in there as well that will self
sabotage and they will,
they,
they will eat junk food and they will
have a cheeseburger and then when this
should really have a salad and they will
watch intellectual junk food when maybe
it would do them better to sit down
and read a book or to watch Nova or to,
you know,
see a documentary.
There's sometimes you don't
want to watch documentary.
You want to watch a bunch of assholes bid
on storage space, you know, and it does,
it doesn't make any fucking sense.
And that's, that's good too.
Like there's no reason that you have
to do serious stuff all day long.
You're right. I, uh, I certainly
don't subscribe to that,
but you're a balanced person and
if you're an imbalance person,
much like people who would
just eat cheeseburgers,
you're going to have
intellectual junk food 24, seven.
You're going to be comforted.
Your mind will be occupied by nonsense.
And that's what we really need.
Our minds are designed to be
occupied by the pursuit of food,
sustenance and sexuality.
That's what we're after.
We're trying to find a place to arrest
someone to fuck something to eat,
keep going, ready, go get up in
the morning. Are you awake? Okay,
fill the needs and now
those needs are filled.
Instead you're plugged into a fucking
video game and you're playing football
with some digital characters
and you're eating pizza,
that some guy actually walked up to your
fucking door and all you had to do is
give them some paper that
means almost nothing,
and he gives you pizza and you stuffing
in your fat face and go right back to
your stupid game.
And it's so easy to do that.
It's so easy to do that as long as you
can do enough to justify enough ones and
Zeros coming into your,
whatever your bank account is these days.
It's not like the vault,
the vaults are filled with paper.
You know what's in that fucking fault?
It's vault filled with paper that's
promising. He promises inside.
It's very strange. It's actually,
uh, there's a great documentary,
I think National Geographic did it on
Fort Knox and all the controversies
surrounding that. What's
important is a no gold, well,
the one of the theories is that the
gold was replaced over time with like
tungsten bars or something because most
people never have access to it anyway.
And governments, governments
swapped their goal all the time.
So they're basically saying,
since there's not much transparency,
we don't know what's actually there. And
it could have been sold off, you know,
20 years ago to some European government.
And what we have here is
just a bunch of blanks.
That sounds like a really good movie.
Yeah.
Like you with Eddie Murphy
and maybe Ben Stiller,
they break into Fort Knox and they
find out there's nothing there. Well,
I think what's more fascinating
stories? No, that's bank heist.
The tower heist diehards almost.
I liked to,
it wasn't precious in tower
heist. Oh yes, she was. Yeah.
The woman from precious.
I think the more fascinating story is
let's take the government at face value
and there's actually hundreds of billions
of dollars of gold in this tiny little,
uh, fort. It's fucking incredible.
It's like something out of ancient
times that we have that, you know. Yeah.
It's like a Mongol hoards. Exactly.
That's pretty preposterous.
The whole thing.
We did the whole society that we
live in this pretty preposterous,
but I think I really do,
uh,
ultimately have faith in the future
and I didn't when I was younger.
I'm more optimistic now than ever before
because I think that ultimately all
there'll be some peaks and valleys in
some happy and sad and some angry in some
happy w the convergence,
the convergence of information and the
convergence of ideas is inevitable.
And I think it will all
balance out because of that.
I think we're going to be forced
because of this new reality,
this new digital reality.
We're going to be forced into
a new level of communication,
a new level of understanding and a new
level of, you know, black community.
That's what I think.
What the fuck do I know?
We could all be like on the way to
enlightenment, all of us doing mushrooms,
holding hands, chanting ohm,
and then we get hit by a meteor.
Boom. I can and start from
scratch. I could happen.
It's interesting that people don't, even
today they don't act purely out of uh,
the need for more paper,
for more money.
Like you look at Reddit and how people
research stuff nonstop and good stuff
rises to the top of the page. They're
just doing that for these Internet points.
For Karma. They're just
doing it. Basically.
Other people will recognize that
they're doing good work this game.
In that though,
and there's also a benefit in that.
There's a social benefit in that when
you feel good, you know, where you,
you make something that
people enjoy already.
We're aspiring to better stuff than just
a choir on it. Yeah. Yeah. That's money.
That is currency.
It's an online currency and you know,
that's what people love about
posting on message boards. You know,
they love getting the, the, the
approval of the people around them.
That's why they get so mad
when they get banned. Oh,
you've taken me out of my hotspot, my
juicy spot. Right. And so much love there.
And I've gotten so much points. You've
cut my cashflow. Yeah, I've cut my, yeah,
that's why I don't think any of
us. We'll unplug. No, it's a,
it's a ridiculous idea. Well,
some people do. I love the people.
I love those mountain men shows when
those, my favorite shows are like Alaska,
the last frontier and mountain men
and ordering a Bering strait gold one.
That one's awesome. Amish people
are going to rule the world. No, no,
because you know what man,
they're boring.
They're wearing their dressing up like
assholes and fucking driving with Rick
[inaudible] to see what he talked. Well
those are the people that do that rumble,
that thing that they do. What is
it called? Rumpl style rumble.
So they have a thing they do when they
become an adult and they're allowed to
leave the church and go balls out and
they get crazy and they party and they
fuck and allowed to do it for
like a year or two or whatever.
And then they're supposed to like make
the decision on whether or not they want
to come back to the church or their snaps.
Are there stats on what percentage?
Say, actually this is better. I'm going to
stay as a no, there's not. You know why?
Because the stats are skewed by the
fact that 100% of all Amish people are
retarded.
So those stats fuck up those other steps.
Do I mean that Amish people know? But
guess what? If you listen to this podcast,
you're not really fucking Amish.
Alright,
so there because this podcast is
illegal in the Amish community,
not allowed to have a podcast.
What's the movie inception about?
I don't know what it's about,
but here's the,
Oh hey, wait, wait, no, hold on. I
mean, what's the movie inception about
inception is about dreaming,
about dreaming, about dreaming,
about dreaming about something or other.
I fell asleep.
How dare you. David's seeming sneak out
to save the league or Brian gets silly.
I think we can wrap this up with some,
a little less doom and gloom, Brian.
You know what I mean? Yeah, yeah.
We're run by a bunch of cunts,
but you know what their cons and they
know their content and they wish they
weren't cuts. So I call out to all eat
cunts gay shit together as cheers. Okay,
all you bitches, I have a
couple of whiskeys. Hug it
out. Go run around the block,
get a yoga class and every now and
again, open up your chakras. Okay?
Open up your heart. Realize you
don't have to be a fucking asshole.
This is not going to last.
And you're caught up in a big trap.
And that big trap is you're trying to
collect all the gold and it doesn't matter
body, it doesn't matter. You could have
half the gold and twice the friends.
You'd be three times as happy.
Boom.
That's Joe Rogan experience
mathematics for you.
At least we found out the real true
ending of the Sopranos today, man.
Fuck James. For folks who don't
know, James Gandolfini died today.
I was in New York two months ago with
my whole family where eating in a
restaurant and a James Gandolfini walked
right by and I was like, Holy Shit.
You know what?
Uh,
what makes me sad about James Gandolfini
die is the same thing that made me
happy about you when you came in today
and told me you were stopped smoking,
that you haven't been smoking.
Right. This is Joey Diaz.
I see Joey Diaz and I see James
Gandolfini and I say, okay,
that's going to happen Joey and I see
you and I think you're not going to live
forever if you live the way you live
and smoking cigarettes. And Yeah,
the reason why I was quitting smoking as
it, cause I tried to hike the other day.
I was like, Holy Shit, my cardio is
fucked up. So I'm thinking about what,
what do you think I should do? I'm
either thinking about doing this, uh,
this girl that was on fear factor
with Yoshi. Uh, she teaches boxing.
She's an MMA boxing trainer.
Uh, and she wants me,
she wants me to train with her hair.
I'll tell you in a second. Hold on.
She wants me to train with her.
Do you think boxing training?
Yeah, it's good. It's great. It's really
hard. It works. Your cardio. Well,
Louis C K does a lot of
that. Yeah, it's great.
And you don't have to actually somebody,
right?
You just hit the bag and hit pads
and most important thing is it's,
it's actually fun to do. It
does. It's not like you know,
it's not getting on an elliptical
machine is sometimes it's really fucking
boring. It's not competitive at
all. So there Carrie Williams,
show me a picture of her. You should do
yoga also. I've gotten really into that.
Yoga is fantastic. And Yoga. Bryan,
you will meet Wu Wei more hot chicks.
That girl, you know her. She was okay.
I wouldn't know her like that.
All Naked and oiled up and shit together.
Oh Wow. I barely remember.
This is the problem.
I was so much prettier than I've really
gotten weird looking starting to fade.
You don't look Italian anymore. You
look more Buddhists again. I'm fat man.
My fucking face is fat. People like
your face is fat. I'm like, yeah, no,
everything's fatter. It's harder to keep
weight off when I'm not doing Jujitsu,
but my back is better than it's ever
been before. For the folks who asked me,
but what I talked about,
what I've been doing is something
called prolozone therapy.
It's prolotherapy with ozone for my
disc issue and a lot of stretching and
spinal decompression.
I can't,
I can't tell you how much better
I feel than just a few months ago.
So if you got any back issues,
don't be sleeping on that shit. Uh,
but so you're going to do boxing
with her? Well, I don't know.
She offered to to train me and
stuff like that, but I don't know.
She probably want some publicity. We'll
give her some, she was on fear factor.
I don't know. I definitely
don't hate her. You know,
I taught saw too many God damn people.
We did,
I don't know how many fucking episode,
the fear factor,
I think it was 148 over six years.
And then each person has at least
each episode, at least six people.
So unfortunately there's no
way I can remember 600 people.
That's that Dunbar's number.
You only get 150 that you
could store inside your brain.
It's not wild to think about.
Yeah.
I wonder how that rotates out if they're
in number. Yeah. I wonder if you,
when you meet somebody new,
somebody else's popping out of your brand,
that's what it is. Yeah. Your,
your, your memory just gets deleted.
Whereas people that live in small towns,
like,
do you ever talk to somebody that grew
up in the same town and see what it
didn't leave and they know all the same
people and they remember everything that
happened in high school and they start
telling you some shit that you did and
you're like, I did that. And they
remember things you don't remember.
You used to date Debbie
Wilson and you're like, fuck,
I forgot about Debbie Wilson.
How the fuck do you know what,
Remember Debbie Wilson?
Why?
Because they don't have as
much information hitting
them on a regular basis as
you do. David Seaman, former
congressional candidate,
bad motherfucker on the Internet.
Your podcast is what sir?
It is the David Seaman and are available
on iTunes. Yeah. Itunes and stitcher.
And if people want to see a positive
side of me, uh, like two interviews ago,
I interviewed terrorists styles.
Who was Deepak Chopra's yoga instructor.
So that's like interviewing mark
Zuckerberg, like social media experts.
It's fucking dope. That's fun. Yeah. And
what did, uh, what did Tara have to say?
Oh she gave me some hangover cure
tips and like being tired tips,
different poses you can try
real and uh, yeah. So uh,
do you park has like a yoga instructor?
It takes care of him or where he goes? Uh,
I don't think he takes her,
she has a studio in New York,
so I don't think that she's like, does
he live in New York? He lives in La.
He lived somewhere out here. And uh, so
how the fuck is he getting yoga from her?
Like skyping in apparently
a couple of years ago,
she talks about it on the
episode a couple of years ago.
He just came up to her and was like,
do you want to be my yoga instructor was
showing know someone else. Sweet. Sweet.
I think they created an iPhone
app together and all that stuff,
but I'm just super into it cause
it's had an impact on my life.
She's not my instructor.
I just interviewed her but
uh, yogas legit. It is,
I do a lot of breathing exercises
and calms your mind so much. Yeah,
it's huge for you.
That's um,
there's a lot of shit that
people figured out before.
They didn't have phones
and nothing else to do.
So like how do we optimize this body
by doing all these stretches and they
figured it out and they wrote it
down and you can learn from it.
It seems like it's nonsense.
Like how can stretching actually make me
feel better but it does some weird shit.
It opens up paths in your brain.
Like I remember I was super nervous.
I've been a super nervous a bunch of
times in my life and the best things that
I've ever done to calm
myself down was yoga.
I was super nervous the first time I
ever did the Howard stern show the night
before. Good News, sleep.
So I just did yoga in my hotel room
and that helps when I was high as fuck.
I did yoga for like two hours and
I just got, hi, I've just hit,
this is total complete calm zone where
the neck, it carried me over the next day.
I didn't worry about anything.
I mean I was still a little bit nervous
when I got there because he was like a
radio hero for me. But once I got in
there I was, it was smooth. I was so calm.
I was so like I felt I was me. I was
100% May. Well I was worried about that.
And uh, the other time, uh,
I had like a really important set that
I was doing in Aspen at the Aspen comedy
festival and I was nervous about it and,
uh,
I remember this has to do with it was
there that I thought was really fucking
annoying. And um, when I
did the yoga like I got,
and this is like total, like
complete accepting, calm,
friendly place.
And I saw the dude that I think is
annoying and normally I'd be like, oh,
look at this fucking Douche bag. Like
this guy's gross. But I immediately,
I was like, poor fella. Yeah.
Like it didn't bother me at all.
I just like it did in my, I didn't
mind. I would've given him a hug.
If you asked for one,
like I didn't care,
I'd hit some some frequency where I
realized that it was manipulatable.
It was you could, you could alter it.
You could alter it with discipline.
You could alter it with consciousness
by consciousness on me and he wu
consciousness.
I mean by deciding yourself like
I would rather be happy than sad.
I would rather be friendly than distant.
I would rather be warm than cold.
So just do it.
Go through the work and these hoses.
It takes two to tango.
It like if somebody is being an asshole
to you after you've taken a yoga class,
you're much slower to react.
Yeah.
You realize that it's not actually a
confrontation until you confront them as
well. Totally. I ran into
some crazy fucking New York.
I was in New York and there was guy at
the park when we were filming the shed of
the park and I thought the guy said
something so I said, I'm sorry.
Excuse me. Like did you say something?
I thought, I thought he said something.
I wasn't being mean all he goes, he goes,
I know you ain't fucking talking to me.
Oh. And, and a, and I go, I thought, uh,
I thought you said something. And he goes,
I know you ain't fucking
talking to me. And I go, well,
I am talking to you obviously,
but I didn't, uh, you know,
I didn't mean to disturb
you. I go, I thought you had
said something. And he goes,
but you ain't fucking talking to me. I
go, I thought I was, I go, my apologies.
He goes, all right, apology accepted. And
they were like ended, but it was like,
I didn't engage at all. Like, instead
of like, man, fuck you dickhead, right,
the fuck are you, you know, instead of
that, instead of like, I'll smack you,
it was like, oh, okay.
You know, whatever, like,
and how many times does that happen where
that guy wound up getting stabbed or
beat up or sent to the hospital or
beat somebody else up or, you know,
distracting himself from his fucking
miserable, pathetic, crazy life.
Because you know, he manages
to get himself involved in
some sort of a conflict.
That was exciting.
Even just taking a pause after
something like that happens like uh, um,
I think more about stuff now I do yoga
and normally I'm really quick to react.
Like I always have some kind of quick
response and in a situation like that now
I'll think like,
do I even have to talk about this?
Do I even have to respond to this crazy
person or is it better to just laugh and
keep walking down the
sidewalk? Well, you know,
Dave Aspery talked about that on the
pockets were just talking about road rage
and he were talking about crazy to think
about, well what he was saying was,
and this is the first time I ever,
ever Hindi had anybody explain it like
this was that when you are driving,
you're going very fast and when you're
going fast you have to be able to make
split second decisions.
So you get locked into this
very pure reptile state of mind,
which just about move, react, do this.
And when someone does something like,
fuck you, it just comes out.
And the reason why it comes out,
it's cause you're ramped up
to react without thinking.
Whereas if you're walking casually,
like down a nice trail in the woods
and someone's coming in the opposite
direction, there would be no road
rage. They'd be like, Hey, what's up?
How you doing? And it would
be gone. You would do,
you'd move out of each other's way.
We used to be locked into
this reptilian frame of mind.
I never really thought about it that way.
Our brains,
our brains are not designed
to go 70 miles an hour.
Absolutely trust me out is that when,
you know, when you go on any flight,
you have a guy sitting in the front of
the plane, he's making you know, whatever,
like 35 or $45,000 a year.
And he's sitting there and he's had to
train himself to move at 500 miles an
hour and keep that shit together for
you for the duration of the flight.
When his, his, uh, you know,
nervous system is designed to deal with
him going at a Max of like 12 miles an
hour and he's doing this and it's
like neatly routine cause that's,
it's crazy. And you paid almost
nothing for it. You know,
you paid like $100 for the flood.
Yeah.
Would you ever watch something and play
tennis like at a high level seem darting
back and forth trying to swat.
That's fucking crazy ball.
This guy reminds me of the matrix because
they're almost anticipating where it's
going to be.
You have to,
cause they're starting to lunch before
it's even gone over the net. Yeah.
You have to see some physical language,
the way their foot turns.
You have to anticipate and then people
will fake people out. Like in football,
I loved the, I don't, my favorite thing.
And football's when someone fakes somebody
out and then spins around and gets
away from them.
You know,
it's like the escape is
even more fascinating than
the hits because it's like
that you gotta be able to anticipate
which way someone's moving and that's,
that's fast for people.
But that ain't shit compared to cars.
When you're in a fucking car and you're
flying down the highway like you're on
reptile 10 you're on this, you're,
you're in this weird frequency.
And that's why people wind up talking to,
cause they were all tents and freaked out.
You're not supposed to go that fast.
That's also why we have
an issue with news.
Cause you're not supposed
to get all the news. Okay,
you're supposed to get the
shit that applies to your
life and that's supposed to
get everything that's happening
with 7 billion people.
And it's supposed to be interactive,
not just you sit in front of a screen
and they tell you all this stuff and you
just take it at face value versus a couple
thousand years ago you're in front of
a fire,
you know the campfire and the guy who
came back from the neighboring tribe tells
you what's going on.
And then a discussion ensues where you
kind of fleshed out how credible is what
this guy is saying. How credible
is this? What does it mean for us?
And now we're seeing that reemerge. You
know, social media, it's a conversation,
stuff like this as a conversation.
And so it's no longer you're looking at
a screen and you have to take everything
Erin Burnett is saying at face value. You
don't, you know, or any of these people,
Piers Morgan,
uh,
who were just shouting at the
screen and in the year 2013,
they think that still works.
And you can tell it's a broken model.
And those conversations pale in comparison
to the conversations that you will
see with those people on the Internet.
Anybody that's a guest on Pierce Morgan,
if they came on your show,
you would have an hour plus two hours,
whatever the fuck you would
have with them, they will,
you would have a way more
of an understanding of who
they really are coming off
for your show than you ever would.
And these seven minute chunks
of conversation sandwiched
in between commercial
breaks and, and, and buttons where
they like, Whoa, we're wrap this up.
You know, like I, uh,
the first time I did your
show I was pretty squirrely
because I'm used to doing,
you know, like four or five minute TV or
radio segments, but they're like, art,
we're having you on to talk about Nda,
just lay it out for us. And it's like,
it's impossible to lay out the whole
history and how it got to that point in
four minutes. So you're just trying
to boil down a couple of good points,
get it out there in a way that people
will think about and hopefully Google the
fucking shit on their own,
but you can't possibly dive in.
And then you get on a show like this,
like, oh, I actually can just be myself.
You can do yourself and your no to
yourself for a long period of time.
And I think that's, uh, that's what
people are looking forward today. They're,
they're, they're looking for,
they're looking for reality.
They have access to reality at in
99% of the places they look where
they don't get it. Is politics
the view of the world? Yeah.
Media is media. Yeah. But everywhere else,
usually looking at people really
cutting people's heads off. Look,
there's the video. Mexican drug lord
cuts his girlfriend's head off. Yup.
There it is. I got eaten by a hip out
yet I'm watching him get eaten. Yup,
he's dead. Oh, look at that. That
guy can't run as fast as the tiger.
What a shocker. Yeah. I mean,
you're getting that reality over
and over and over and over again,
and it's harder and harder to take the
spoon fed bullshit when the Internet
provides you with reality
in 99% of the instances.
Well,
in the 70s journalism was about you'd
want to appear to be unbiased because that
was acquainted with
professionalism for some reason,
so we ended up being in Vietnam for far
longer than we could have been because
all of these guys there,
they didn't want to insult their audience
by giving them their opinions like, oh,
it's actually,
this is fucked up for us to have Americans
coming back in body bags for some
more that we don't need to be involved,
and they would never say that
on the evening news. Instead.
They would just be very clinical about it.
But sometimes you need people who've done
the research and then come out and say,
this is why this is a big deal.
This is why you should be upset
or this is why you shouldn't care.
But they didn't do that at all.
If the height of you know,
network journalism and then until very
recently you've seen that creep into
everything. Like people who
even work at really big blogs,
you see they lose some of their voice
because they're like, it's not my,
not my position to tell you what to
think, but really it is. It's your you,
it's my position to tell you what
I think and why I think that.
And then you can come along for the
ride or you can go another direction.
But to not do that I think
is really dishonest. And
you read the New York Times,
which is on your tablet, on your iPad. So
it's competing with all this new stuff.
It's better. And they're still, they have
this weird like shine of objectivity.
So like they can't just tell
you what they actually think.
It has to be Mr. Obama is paying up to
$100 million for his vacation and there's
no notation like we disagree with this.
It's just here's what's happening
as a figurehead. It doesn't work
anymore. As a, as a label is a, you know,
box that you put all your stuff into. It
doesn't work anymore. You, I, it's like,
it's almost like that expression.
Let the market decide.
You really want to let the market decide
whose opinions are valid and there's
problems with that too.
There's definitely like people will find
people that reinforced their opinions.
We'll get Glenn back. That's one of the
best examples is the perfect example. Oh,
send me his shit cause he does this
marketing tactic. We'll say the NSA leak,
we've got our own whistle blower.
Uh, it's coming out in 24 hours.
It's like if you have this, why don't
you just come out with it right now?
You've got to make people visit your
website again and again over the next 24
hours. And then he actually
comes out with, and it's never,
I don't watch enough Glenn
Beck to know if this is true,
so I don't want to disparage the guy,
but as far as I've seen his big blowout
things that are supposed to change the
world and everything will be different.
Never end up delivering
even a 10th on that promise.
Fuck Glenn Beck and all praise
David Seaman. Ladies and gentlemen,
you're a bad motherfucker dude.
I really enjoyed talking to him.
We got to do this more often. My
powerful Joe Rogan. Powerful David.
See we're making shit happen out there.
One Internet viewer at a time.
Thank you everybody for uh, did you,
did you unveil that tee shirt yet?
When are you available that
it's going to be a presale?
Hopefully later this week, if not
next week. There's the newest, latest,
greatest desk squad tee shirt. The
best ever for sure by far. Oh yeah.
As soon as I saw it, I'm like, you hit
it out of the park kids. It's bad ass.
The newest desk squad version
number three by Brian red band.
And that will be out probably
at the end of this week.
We'll do a podcast tomorrow with the
lovely and talented Jason Silva who I ran
into at a the g four 2045 conference.
We'll have a lot of crazy shit to talk
about. That dude was on fire. He's,
he loves technology. So he went fucking
crazy when I talked to him last.
He's awesome. So He'd be here tomorrow,
tomorrow afternoon, and then, um,
maybe we'll do something this weekend too.
I don't know what's going on,
but it's going crazy doing this TV
show, trying to make it happen. Uh,
thank you to the sponsors of the podcast.
Go to squarespace.com forward slash Joe,
um,
enter in the code named Joe and the
number six and you will save yourself 10%
off. That's squarespace.com
forward slash Joe and Joe six,
all one word.
Thanks also to on [inaudible]
dot com if you go to o,
n n I t use the code name Rogan,
you will save yourself 10% off any.
And all magical nutritional supplements
were also brought to you by legal zoom,
legal zoom.
If you go to legal zoom.com
and use the code deem Rogan,
you will save yourself some cash and save
yourself a lot more than you would pay
if you went to a lawyer.
Legal zooms out a law firm.
They provide self help services
at your specific direction.
How faith that says, Oh shit, bitches.
I can fake. I want to have to.
All right. Um, uh, all the love.
Thank you very much everybody. Thanks. Uh,
for all the people that came out
to see me and a timely Segura.
I've been winning pay. We had a
good time. My friends in Canada,
Canada is beautiful,
man.
People are so God damn nice up
there on my Toronto shows sold out.
So they're adding waterfall
Brian, right? Tony Hinchcliffe.
Anybody else? Just you too. Yep. Just
us. Yeah, that place is beautiful.
Good luck trying to stay
sober. All right, you freaks.
We'll see you tomorrow afternoon.
Probably same time ish with the Great
Jason Silva Jihad and praise Odin.